HEY OF GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I'M
GLAD TO SEE SO MUCH INTEREST IN
OUR AGENDA TODAY SENATOR -- GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER.
FOUR I WANT TO THANK YOUNG.
A SILENCE AND ALL THE WORK OF
THE STAFF ON THE COMMITTEE THE
LA -- AND ARM IN A FINANCE
THANKS TO EVERYBODY WHO.
CONTRIBUTES TO OF THE SUCCESS OF
THESE MEETINGS.
AND THIS THE AND THIS COMMITTEE
SO FIRST WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP --
ARE VOTE ONLY ITEMS -- I'M SORRY
QUORUM [inaudible]
SO.
SENATOR UP DRAWS A YEAR SENATOR
NIELSEN CENTER I'M BURKE.
OKAY.
SO ON THE FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS TO TAKE OF THE VOTE
ONLY ITEMS.
ARE THE ISSUES.
THAT FALL UNDER THAT OR ISSUE
ONE THROUGH ISSUE -- FOURTEEN DO.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WANT TO REMOVE ANY ITEMS FROM
THE VOTE ONLY.
NUMBER NO.
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE PUBLIC THAT WANTS TO COMMENT.
ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
NO HEARING NONE IS THERE A
MOTION TO MOVE THESE ITEMS.
THIS CALL THE ROLL SENATOR DRAWS
A I CENTER NIELSEN CENTER I'M
BURKE [inaudible]
OKAY GREAT.
ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S SOME LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE -- FIFTEEN OKAY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIFTEEN
SECRETARY OF GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
DO NOT YET OFFICIALLY.
BUT YOU ARE OFFICIALS I AM A
FISH I I'VE BEEN APPOINTED I AM
I WILL BE SWORN IN TOMORROW SO
YOU'RE GETTING ME ON MY LAST DAY
AS SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND JUST BEFORE I
BECOME THE GOVERNOR SPECIAL
ADVISER ON INNOVATION AND
DIGITAL SERVICES.
WELCOME CONGRADULATIONS THANK
YOU.
ARE YOU GONNA TALK TO US ABOUT
THE OFFICE DIGITAL INNOVATION I
AM OKAY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR FOR
YEAH YEAH MADAM MADAM MADAM
CHAIR SENATOR UMBERG.
I MICHAEL WILL CONTAIN RECENTLY
APPOINTED AS THE GOVERNOR
SPECIAL ADVISER ON INNOVATION
AND DIGITAL SERVICE SAYS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL.
AS YOU KNOW GOVERNMENTS FOR TOO
LONG HAVE NEGLECTED TO THINK
ABOUT THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE
BEEN DELIVERING.
GOVERNMENT SERVICES AND
FUNCTIONS WHETHER IN PERSON
THROUGH THE MAIL OR EVEN ONLINE.
AS WE BROUGHT TECHNOLOGY AND OUR
WORK WE'VE LARGER FOCUSED ON
AUTOMATING THE EXISTING PROCESS
SEES.
AND WORK WAS BASED ON HOW WE
THINK THANK SHOULD WORK.
ARE TOO OFTEN BUT WE FAILED ASK
ACTUAL PEOPLE.
AND THAT WE SERVE WHAT THEY
WOULD LIKE THAT ACCESS TO LOOK
LIKE WHAT'S HELPFUL FOR THEM OR
EVEN HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT THE
SERVICES THEY'RE BEING PROVIDED
TO THEM.
I INVESTMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY
HISTORICALLY BEEN LARGELY ONE
ONE OFF ONE DEPARTMENT ONE
SOLUTION APPROACHES AND THEY
ONLY HAPPEN AFTER AN INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENT COMES IN WITH A
SPECIFIC DEPARTMENT ON THE NO
LONGER VIABLE APPROACH TO
MEETING THE PUBLIC'S
EXPECTATIONS.
TECHNOLOGIES RADICALLY CHANGED
OUR LIVES AND THE SOCIETY WE
LIVE IN FROM HOW AND WHERE WE
GET INFORMATION.
CONDUCTOR FINANCIAL AFFAIRS SHOP
ACCESS ENTERTAINMENT INTERACT
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
THE WORLD IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN
EVEN A DECADE AGO.
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR COMPANIES
COMPETE FOR CUSTOMERS ATTENTION
IN BUSINESS BY DELIVERING WORLD
CLASS USER EXPERIENCES THEY
FOCUS ON THE CUSTOMER AND SO
SHOULD GOVERNMENT.
THIS PROPOSAL.
IS ABOUT CHANGING CULTURE.
VALUING INNOVATION INVESTING IN
OUR WORK FORCE.
DELIVERING GOVERNMENT SERVICES
IN A WAY THAT IS ACCESSIBLE
MEANINGFUL AND INTUITIVE TO THE
PUBLIC WE SERVE.
IMPROVING CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
RECOGNIZING THE INHERENT RISK IN
THE STATUS QUO APPROACHES THAT
WE CURRENTLY YEARS.
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
REASONABLE RISK TAKING IS NOT
ONLY ACCEPTABLE BUT ENCOURAGE.
IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE
BACK.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT BIG IT AND BIG
PROJECTS.
THE PROPOSAL IS GENERALLY BASED
ON SUCCESSFUL MODELS WE'VE SEEN
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD STARTING
WITH THE U. K. DIGITAL SERVICE.
AND HERE AT HOME WITH THE US
DIGITAL SERVICE IN EIGHTEEN NOW
FEDERAL LEVEL.
THE SAN FRANCISCO DIGITAL
SERVICES AND OTHER DIGITAL
SERVICES AT VARIOUS LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT ROUTE THE WORLD.
MOST PAUL FOLLOWS SIMILAR WELL
ESTABLISHED LABOR.
WHAT IS IT CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES BOTH THE
SECRETARY AND UNDERSECRETARY?
WE STARTED LAYING A FOUNDATION
WHICH THIS OFFICE CAN SCALE AND
BUILD ON WE STARTED WITH THE
OPEN DATA.
WE JUST STARTED FOCUSING ON THE
CLIENT LOOKING AT WHAT SERVICES
WE PROVIDE A PROCESS.
BY WHICH PLANTS RECENT
APPROXIMATE WELL SERVICES AND
AND DEPARTMENTS.
WE STARTED LOOKING AT OUR
INTERNAL DATA.
AND USING THAT TO INFORM
DECISIONS AND PROVIDE INSIGHTS
INTO HOW THE PROGRAMS WERE
OPERATING.
WE ESTABLISHED THAT THE FIRST
INNOVATION OFFICE IN THE STATE.
AND WITH THE FIRST APPOINTED --
INNOVATION DIRECTOR SHANEAH ONE
OFTEN WHO'S HERE IN THE AUDIENCE
ALONG WITH HIS DEPUTY CONRAD
RESENTED.
THAT OFFICE IS COMPRISED
COMPLETELY A STATE STAFF ON ONTO
YOUR ROTATIONS -- I THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO LOOK AT A COMBINATION
OF BOTH STATE.
AND PRIVATE SECTOR INDIVIDUALS
TO BRING AND WHICH IS MUCH LIKE
WITH THE US DIGITAL SERVICE DOES
AND IT'S MODEL.
IT PROVIDES THAT.
THAT INSIGHT INTO HOW GOVERNMENT
OPERATES BUT ALSO THAT THE IDEAS
THAT ARE COMING OUT OF THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
IN DIFFERENT WAYS TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS THAT WERE SAYING.
WE ALSO -- AND CAN I AND
COOPERATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY AND THE GOVERNMENTAL
OPERATIONS AGENCY.
COMMITTED TO AN AGILE MODULAR
PROCUREMENT ON THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM RATHER THAN DOING OF
LARGE. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PAYMENT TO ONE VENDOR AND
THEN HAVING THAT TAKE TEN YEARS
BEFORE YOU GOT ANY CODE THAT YOU
COULD ACTUALLY LOOK AT WHAT THAT
DOES IS IT ALLOWS THE THE END
USER IN THAT CASE THE CASE
MANAGERS -- OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AGENCY.
ACTUALLY ENGAGE WITH THE PRODUCT
AND GIVE YOU FEEDBACK ON HOW
THAT'S WORKING OR NOT WORKING
FOR THEIR THEIR JOBS.
I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND HOW STATE
EMPLOYEES EMBRACE THIS
OPPORTUNITY BOTH INSIDE THE
OFFICE AND IN THE DEPARTMENTS
WHERE THE PROJECTS TAKE PLACE.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT AND IN MY
DISCUSSIONS WITH ALL THE OTHER
INNOVATION OFFICES OR DIGITAL
SERVICES OFFICE I'VE TALKED TO
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
THE SUCCESS OF THESE MODELS IS
DEPENDENT ON ACTIVE EXECUTIVE
SPONSORSHIP.
IN THIS CASE THE GOVERNOR
HIMSELF IS IS INVOLVED IN THAT.
KEY GOALS FOR THE OFFICE ARTIST
I WISH A CULTURE OF INNOVATION
CUSTOMER CENTRIC MINDSET FOCUS
ON BUSINESS PROCESS IMPROVEMENT.
UTILIZE AGILE IN OPEN APPROACHES
TO HOW WE BUILD AND BUY THINGS.
TRANSPARENCY AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING OPEN DATA.
COLLABORATION SHAREABLE IN
REUSABLE SOLUTIONS AND KNOWLEDGE
TRANSFER. TO THAT END WERE
REQUESTED INITIAL START OF
RESOURCES OF THIRTY SIX POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. FOURTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING FIFTY POSITIONS TO
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY.
THE OFFICE WILL HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP AND ENFORCE
REQUIREMENTS BUT APARTMENTS TO
ASSESS THEIR SERVICE DELIVERY
MODELS.
AND UNDERLYING BUSINESS
PROCESSES FROM A CUSTOMER OR END
USER PERSPECTIVE.
KEEP UP COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDE AND INNOVATION
ACADEMY.
THE SUSTAINABLE INNOVATION
REQUIRES A CULTURE CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT.
AND I THOUGHT.
YOU MEANT CHANGE MANAGEMENT.
THESE ARE TWO AREAS THE
GOVERNMENT HAS HAS NOT TEMPTER
PLAY WELL AND AND THAT'S JUST.
BROADLY BUT CALIFORNIA IS NOT AN
EXCEPTION TO THAT.
THE OFFICE WILL ADDRESS THOSE
NEEDS CREATION OF A SCALABLE
INNOVATION ACADEMY STOCK
CONTINUOUS PROCESS IMPROVEMENT
EVEN CHANGE MANAGEMENT EXECUTIVE
SPONSORSHIP.
AND A CUSTOMER CENTRIC MINDSET.
ACADEMY WILL BE MANDATORY FOR
STATE SUPERVISORS MANAGERS AND
EXECUTIVES.
WITH THE BREAK DOWN THE LINE TO
THE AUDIENCE THAT'S PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT IN ORDER FOR ANY OF
THESE THINGS TO TAKE ROOT YOU
NEED EXECTIVE SPONSORSHIP NEED
THE MANAGEMENT THE ACTION
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED.
WHITE OFTEN THAT THE STAFF
ALREADY UNDERSTAND THESE THESE
CONCEPTS.
AND THEY NEED THE SUPPORT
ACTUALLY START TO THEM.
WILL ALSO -- INCLUDING HERE'S
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY TRAINING.
OUR STATE STAFF AN AGILE AND
OTHER MODERN MODERN DEVELOPMENT
METHODS. TO IMPROVE SUCCESSFUL
SERVICE DELIVERY WITH A FOCUS ON
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT.
SO AS I SAID WE HAVE IT WITH THE
CHILD WELFARE DIGITAL SERVICE
SAYS -- WITH THAT RETIREMENT
YOU'VE ALREADY BEGUN INVESTING A
MODULAR THURMOND NIGEL METHOD OF
DELIVERY -- WHEN IMPLEMENTED
CORRECTLY?
THOSE AND REDUCE THE RISK OF
PROJECT FAILURES.
AND I THINK EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY ENGAGE THE END USER
SO THAT WHAT YOU'RE GETTING AT
THE END OF SOMETHING THAT
ACTUALLY USABLE FOR FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT THE NEED TO USE THE
SYSTEM.
THE STATE'S CURRENT PROJECT
MANAGERS GENERALLY DON'T HAVE
THAT EXPERTISE AND IN MANAGING
THIS THIS NEW WAY OF DOING.
PARTICULAR AN AGILE DEVELOPMENT.
AND THEN THE PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES AN INNOVATION.
SO IT'S A ONE TIME FUNDING A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO ALLOW
THE OFFENSE TO ASSIST
DEPARTMENTS BUT WILSON RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS.
THAT NEED.
TO INTENDED TO ALLOW THE OFFICE
TO MOVE QUICKLY TO ADDRESS
ISSUES AND PROVIDE SOLUTIONS IN
REAL TIME.
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT IMPORTANT
CHANGE FROM EXISTING BUDGET AND
I. T. PROJECT WE WILL PROCESS
SEES WHICH HAD YEARS TO TIME
LINES LEAVE THE LARGE PROJECT
PROPOSALS AND FORCED BY ONLY
RISKY AND A LARGE SCALE SYSTEM
APPLICATION.
I KNOW IT'S THE IT'S IT'S GONNA
BE IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND HOW THAT ON BEING YOU SINCE
THAT PART OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
FOR THAT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT OVERLAP BETWEEN
EXISTING OFFICES AND WHAT THIS
OFFICE WOULD USE OF BRENT SPENCE.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES --
THAT THAT HAS NOW BEEN OFF BEST.
THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY HAS A
IN AN ODI AS WELL WE'RE GONNA
REMAIN NOT SO THAT WE CAN GET
RID OF THE FUSION THERE.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THAT THESE ARE COMPLEMENTARY
ROLES THIS IS NOT.
SAME THINGS IN FACT CD TEASE
FOCUS MORE ON ON THE THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY STAFF.
THIS IS FOCUSED MORE ON THE
EXECUTIVE SPONSORSHIP.
THE MANAGEMENT STAFF WROTE THE
PROGRAM STAFF.
THIS IS NOT REALLY ABOUT IT ON
THIS SIDE.
AND SO WE THINK THAT THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE COMPLIMENTARY
COMPLEMENTARY ROLES RATHER THAN.
INNER OVERLAP.
SO -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION PUZZLE AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- YOU WANT.
YES -- I'M SORRY YES -- BRIAN
MASSACRE ALEJO -- WE WROTE A
BUDGET AND POLICY POST ON THIS
PARTICULAR GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
WORRY RAISED SEVERAL ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION ALL TO
SUMMARIZE THEM THE THREE MAIN
AREAS.
THE FIRST OF WHICH IS THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE RELATIVE TO
THIS NEW OFFICE I'M PARTICULARLY
IN THE CRITERIA USED TO SELECT
THOSE PROJECTS THAT ARE GONNA BE
FUNDED WITH THE INNOVATION FUND
MONIES -- IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION SOME OF
THOSE CRITERIA WILL INCLUDE
THINGS SUCH AS THE POLICY
INTERESTS OF THE ADMINISTRATION --
FEEDBACK FROM MANAGERS AND
EXECUTIVES THAT ATTEND THIS NEW
INNOVATION ACADEMY AS WELL AS A
DEPARTMENTS READING THIS
ACTUALLY ENGAGE THE NEW OFFICE
IN THESE PROPOSALS AND SO.
THERE'S NOT A CLEAR ROLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN DEFINING WHAT --
ITS INTERESTS ARE IN SELECTING
THE DEPARTMENTS -- THERE'S ALSO
THE ISSUE OF OVERSIGHT -- AS
THAT -- AS WAS MENTIONED --
RELATED TO THE CURRENT -- BUDGET
PROCESS RELATIVE TO THIS TWENTY
MILLION IN A ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION THAT'S CURRENTLY
THROUGH THEIR BUDGET BILLING
WHICH ON SUBJECT ANY STRINGS
ATTACHED -- AT THIS TIME ON THE
SECOND ISSUE IS AROUND THIS
ISSUE OF DEFINING CD T. ARMOR
TECHNOLOGY RELATIVE TO THE NEW
OFFICE -- WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE RULES MAY BE
COMPLEMENTARY TO THE EXTENT THAT
pFUNDING AND POSITIONS IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION -- INTENDS TO
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO MAINTAIN THE
FUNDING IN POSITIONS THAT IT
DOES HAVE -- RATHER THAN
REVERTING THE SAVINGS BACK TO
THE STATE SO IT IS IMPORTANT WE
BELIEVE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THAT'S
APPROPRIATE -- DECISION TO BE
MADE AND THE LAST.
PIECE OF THIS IS WHETHER THE
ACTUAL PROPOSED AND LEVEL OF
FUNDING IN POSITIONS -- IS IS
REALISTIC OR OR COULD BE
ACHIEVED GIVEN THAT WE HAD
DIFFICULTY IN THE PAST HIRING IT --
WE APPRECIATE THAT NOT ALL THE
STAFF WILL BE DIRECTLY INVOLVED
IN I. T. -- BUT THERE MAY BE
DIFFICULTY RAMPING UP IN ONE
YEAR I'M FIFTY POSITIONS FOR
THIS NEW OFFICE AND SO --
DEFINING THAT UP FRONT AS WELL
AS LOOKING INTO THE FUTURE WHAT
THE ON GOING FUNDING POSITIONS
WILL BE DIFFERENT KIND OF THE
MISSION OF THIS NEW OFFICE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DID YOU HAVE.
YES A DEPARTMENT OF THAT ROUND
ROBIN FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL'S BUDGETED -- AND WE WE
DO HAVE SOME PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT SPECIFIES THAT THE
IN AT ONE TIME INNOVATION
FUNDING SHALL BE USED TO ASSIST
DEPARTMENTS AND THEIR INNOVATION
ACTIVITIES WE DON'T FIND WHAT
INNOVATION ACTIVITIES ARE BUT
THERE IS SOME LANGUAGE.
IN THE BUDGET BILL THAT THAT.
A SPECIFIES WHAT THAT FUNDING
WILL BE USED [inaudible]
FOR OKAY.
YES I WOULD DO ON A SH WELL YOU
WILL RESPOND TO THOSE QUESTIONS
ARE -- SO ON ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE AND WE'RE
WE'RE ALWAYS OPEN TO IDEAS THAT
THEIR THINGS THE LEGISLATURE
PARTICULARLY WANTS TO HAVE
LOOKED AT I DON'T THINK THAT WE
WOULD BE OPPOSED TO TO LOOK INTO --
CURRENTLY AT THAT THE HHS
ANIMATION OFFICE THE IDEAS.
THE PROJECTS COME FROM THE
DEPARTMENTS THEMSELVES.
AND SO -- THERE MAY BE INSTANCES
WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION WANTS
TO SAY THAT THIS IS A PRIORITY
IN THE OFFICE IS GOING TO LOOK
INTO IT.
BUT IN A LOT OF CASES I WOULD
WANT THOSE COMING OUT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT'S INSTEAD SAID
THERE'S BY AND FROM THE
DEPARTMENT.
IS IS VERY IMPORTANT IN THIS
TYPE OF PROJECT THAT YOU HAVE.
A PAIRING OF THE DEPARTMENTAL
STAFF WHO UNDERSTAND THE PROGRAM
THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY'RE HAVING.
ALONG WITH THE EXPERT IN THE IN
THE NEW APPROACHES.
AND THEN IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT FOR
THE LONGER TERM THAT THE
DEPARTMENT BUYS INTO IT SO THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT THE SOLUTION.
RATHER THAN SOMEBODY COME AND
TELL YOU THIS IS WHAT YOU SHOULD
DO WALK AWAY AND THEN YOU SAY
WELL WE'RE DONE WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING BACK TO THE WAY THAT.
WE'VE DONE IT ASI SAID THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT CULTURAL CHANGE.
SO THE PROJECT REALLY
INCREMENTALLY THE LEAD TO EIGHT
SHIFT IN THE THE CULTURE OF THE
DEPARTMENTS.
THE ONE THAT'S FOCUSED ON
INNOVATION FOCUSED ON DIFFERENT
WAYS OF APPROACHING PROBLEMS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY FOCUSED ON
THEIR END USERS -- AS FAR AS THE
SAVINGS I I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SAVINGS AT THE MOMENT
I I'M NOT SEEING A LOT OF
OVERLAP BETWEEN.
THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AND
THE PROPOSED OFFICE SO WE WE
DON'T SEE THAT THERE ARE SAVINGS
THERE COULD BE SOME.
COULD BE SCORED -- WERE OPEN TO
THAT CONVERSATION OF PEOPLE SEE
MORE OVERLAP AND I'M SAYING I
I'M OPEN OF THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT THAT OVERLAP LOOKS
LIKE.
AND AS FAR AS HIRING HIRING IS
DIFFICULT AND AND WE'RE GOING TO
HIRE GOOD PEOPLE INTO THESE
POSITIONS.
THEY'RE NOT REALLY -- GONNA BE
THERE MAY BE SOME MIGHTY PEOPLE
BUT A LOT OF THEM ARE NOT GOING
TO BE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY.
POSITIONS BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
STUFF THAT WE'RE DOING -- AT HHS
SOMEWHAT INVISION.
THEM DURING THE OFF THE DIGITAL
INNOVATION IS REALLY AROUND
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT.
AND DIFFERENT WAYS OF
APPROACHING APPROACHING PROBLEMS
SOME OF IT MAY HAVE AN IT
COMPONENT TO IT BUT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE AN I. T. DRIP AND
PROCESS [inaudible]
OKAY -- THANK YOU SECTOR WILL
MEAN. TO THE POINT YOU MADE
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY SO.
A YEAR FROM NOW HOW DO WE FIGURE
OUT WHETHER THIS BEEN IS BEEN AN
EFFECTIVE USE OF TAXPAYER MONEY
WHAT WHAT METRICS ARE WE GONNA
USED TO JUDGE WHETHER THIS IS
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT [inaudible]
SO.
A YEAR FROM NOW AND THE FIRST
STEP IS GOING TO BE GETTING A
DIRECTOR FOR FOR THE OFFICE AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO A WIDE
SEARCH FOR THAT AND IT'S A
RELATIVELY SMALL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO I THINK ARE IN THAT.
WILL THAT THEY WOULD REALLY WANT
IS THAT REALLY HIGH CALIBER
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS ABLE TO
DELIVER ON THAT SO I AM LOOKING
FOR SOMEBODY WHO CAN HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING.
AND THAT WILL GIVE ME AN IDEA OF
WHAT I CAN ACTUALLY DELIVER
WITHIN A YEAR.
WHAT I WOULD WANT IS THAT WE WE
HAVE THE TRAINING CURRICULUM UP
AND WE'RE STARTING TO TRAIN UP
EXECUTIVES THAT WE CAN COME BACK
TO YOU AND SAY HERE'S HERE'S
WHAT THE TRAINING PROGRAM LOOKS
LIKE HERE'S HOW MANY PEOPLE WE
TRAINED?
HERE THE THINGS WERE STARTING TO
SEE OUT OF THAT AND SOME OF THE
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE CHANGING
BASED ON THE FEEDBACK THEY WERE
GETTING.
SO I THINK IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THIS OFFICE LIVES BY WHAT
IT'S ALSO MOUSING WHICH IS THAT.
WE CHANGE AS WE LEARN WE
CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE PEOPLE
WE CONTINUE TO GET FEEDBACK AND
THEN WE SHIFT AS WE NEED TO TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE END USER --
I ALSO THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW ITIS QUITE POSSIBLE
THAT WILL HAVE SOME PROJECTS
DONE WITHIN A YEAR -- BECAUSE WE
CAN GET SOME SMALLER PROJECTS
AND PROBABLY BRING THOSE UP WE
CAN SCALE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING ITS C. HHS
AND START TO SCALE -- OUT TO THE
THE BROADER STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS.
AND SO I THINK WE'LL WE'LL BE
ABLE TO COME BACK WITH SOME
ACTUAL SUCCESSES AND SAY HERE'S
WHAT WE'VE DONE TO IMPROVE THE
WAY THAT WERE APPROACHING
PROBLEMS.
HERE'S WHAT WE'VE DONE TO
IMPROVE DATA SHARING ACROSS
DEPARTMENTS HERE'S WHAT WE'VE
DONE TO GET A BETTER VIEW OF
WHAT SERVICES ARE PROVIDING TO
INDIVIDUALS AND WHAT.
IT BACK IS ON WHAT THAT SERVICE
LOOKS LIKE.
WE SHOULD ALSO WITHIN A YEAR
HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF WHAT THE
FUTURE OF THE OFFICE REALLY IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
SO I THINK WITHIN THAT YEAR WE
NEED TO BE FIGURING OUT WHERE WE
GOING TO FOCUS.
AND START MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION AND SO.
YEAH IT IT'S NOT GONNA BE NOW
WE'RE STARTING WITHOUT STAFF AT
THE MOMENT SO I'M NOT GONNA TELL
YOU THERE'S GOING TO BE A HUGE
DELIVERABLE.
THAT WE PUT IN FRONT OF YOU AT
THE END OF A YOU KNOW A YEAR
FROM NOW.
BUT I DO EXPECT THAT THEY'LL BE
SOME SOME PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS.
IN MOVING TOWARDS MOVING THE
CULTURE OF OF THE STATE AGENCIES
AT LEAST AND POCKETS.
AND THEN I THINK THAT THAT'S
SCALABLE OUT OVER THE COMING
YEARS.
THE CONCERN IS IS THAT WHEN WE
CREATE A NEW GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
ORGANIZATION WITHOUT A DEFINED
SORT OF PRODUCT.
IN STATE.
THAT THAT ORGANIZATION EXISTS.
JUST TO EXIST THE YEARS THAT
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT THAT IT'S
JUST SELF PERPETUATING.
SO WHETHER IT'S A YEAR TWO YEARS
FROM NOW YOU EXPECT THAT THAT
THEY'LL BE ACTUAL PRODUCT THAT
WE PRODUCE THAT WE CAN SAY WE
HAVE NOW.
EITHER CREATED WE LANDED A MAN
ON THE MOON OR WOMAN ON THE MOON
OR WE'VE DONE SOMETHING.
THAT IMPROVES THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SOME FASHION IS.
A CAB SO THAT'S A WE SHOULD LOOK
FOR YOU TO LOOK FOR THOSE THINGS
WE SHOULD A YEAR EARLIER.
I MEAN SOME WEBSITES SO THAT
THERE'S BETTER ACCESS IS BETTER
UNDERSTANDING.
LOOKING AT HOW PEOPLE APPLY FOR
EVERY DIFFERENT BENEFITS.
HOW WE MONITOR WHAT BENEFITS ARE
BEING USED SO SORTS OF THINGS
SHOULD BE DONE I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO THINK ABOUT METRICS SO TO
THE POINT YOU JUST MADE?
YOU KNOW HOW MANY YOU KNOW MORE
HITS DO WE WHAT A MAKING THINGS
UP NOW BUT HOW MANY MORE HIS DO
WE HAVE HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE OF
WE PROVIDED SERVICE.
HOW MUCH MONEY HAVE WE SAVE HOW
MUCH QUICKER HAVE WE DONE
SOMETHING?
SO THAT.
WE WE CAN ACTUALLY TO THE POINT
ABOUT.
ACCOUNTABILITY OF LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHTS WE CAN SAY HEY WE WE
SPENT THIS MONEY AND HERE'S WHAT
WE'VE DELIVERED.
FOR CALIFORNIA -- LASTLY I'M
BACK NEW GOVERNMENT AGAIN -- BUT
I NOTICE YOU DIDN'T USE THE WORD
SYNERGY INTERFACE DIALOGUE YOU
DO USE LEVERAGING SO.
IS I'VE NOTICED THAT UNLESS
SOMEBODY USES THOSE THREE TERMS
SYNERGY INTERFACE AND DIALOGUE
THAT IT MAY NOT BE A VIABLE
PROGRAM CELL -- WILL HAVE TO
WORK ON ALL RIGHT OKAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible] SEVEN OKAY --
I HAVE TO ADMIT I'M I'M STILL.
SOMEWHAT NOT CONFUSE BUT IT
SEEMS SO GENERAL AND SO VAGUE
AND I AM I REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE WAY THAT YOU'VE LAID OUT.
THE THE BROAD BROAD GOALS OF
CHANGING CULTURE IMPROVING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT RISK TAKING.
I GET THAT AND I'M ALL FOR THAT.
BUT I STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IT WHAT WHAT THAT MEANS
REALLY?
TRANSLATING THAT INTO REAL
THINGS FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA -- SO SO IT JUST AND
THEN THE THE SECOND PART IS THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED.
AT LEAST WITHIN YOUR PREVIOUS
DEPARTMENT.
RIGHT AND MAYBE A FEW OTHER
EXAMPLES OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING OR
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE.
AND THERE. TO THIS POINT
SUCCESSFUL EXAMPLES OF WHAT CAN
BE DONE.
SO WHY IS A NEW.
WHOLE NEW DEPARTMENT WITH FIFTY
MORE PEOPLE AND THIS MONEY WHY
IS THAT NEEDED IF.
THROUGH YOUR OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE HERE.
YOU SEE YOU'VE SEEN WHAT CAN BE
DONE IN THE DEPARTMENTS.
IT IS NOT AS YOU SAID IS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE UNLESS THERE
IS BY AND BY PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND TO HAVE THE PRACTICAL
EXPERIENCE OF WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHAT'S NOT WHAT.
WHAT'S GOOD AND WHAT IS AN WOULD
STILL BE LEFT OUT.
SO.
I STILL DON'T GET WHERE.
SOMETHING IS GONNA NEED LEAD TO
THE ON SOMETHING BETTER.
THAT WE NEED A GOVERNMENT RIGHT
AND AND THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION --
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE POINTS IS THAT TO REALLY DO
THIS STATEWIDE YOU NEED A
CENTRAL ORGANIZATION THAT'S ABLE
TO DO IT.
AND AND APPROPRIATELY RESOURCE
SO WHAT WE WE DID IT HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AS WE'VE KIND OF
COBBLED IT TOGETHER AND IT'S
DOING SINCE SOME INTERESTING
WORK AND AND SOME IMPACTFUL WORK
FOR INSTANCE WE WE LOOKED AT
WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN
PROGRAM AND CAL BRASH.
AND LOOKING TO SEE WHAT THE
OVERLAP WAS -- IN THOSE PROGRAMS.
AT THE CENSUS TRACK LEVEL SO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHICH
COUNTIES ARE DOING A GOOD JOB
ENROLLING PEOPLE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS.
WHICH ONES ARE HAVING SOME
STRUGGLES WATER BEST PRACTICES
TO HELP THEM BUT ALSO TO GIVE
THAT INFORMATION BACK TO
COUNTIES AT THE CENSUS TRACK
LEVEL.
SO THAT THEY CAN THEN DO
TARGETED AND OUTRAGE RATHER THAN
A GENERAL APPROACH TO THEIR CAL
FRESH PROGRAM.
THEY CAN INSTEAD TARGET.
PARTICULAR AREA AND SAY THIS IS
MARIE AND GET THE BEST BANG FOR
THE BUCK -- WERE ALSO STARTING
TO LOOK AT THE THE PROCESS THAT
WE USE TO BRING INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL INDIVIDUALS INTO THE
STATE HOSPITAL.
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT WAIT
LIST FOR YEARS ON IT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN SUED
ON MANY TIMES.
AND THAT WE BUT A LOT OF
RESEARCH THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
THE ADMINISTRATION PUT A LOT OF
RESOURCES AND TO INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF BEDS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE STATE HOSPITALS
AND OTHER WAYS TO ADDRESS THAT.
BUT NOW WORD THROUGH THAT OFFICE
LOOKING AT THE PROCESS ITSELF.
HOW DO YOU GO ABOUT MOVING THAT
THROUGH DAY THE COUNTIES AND
THROUGH THE STATE AND ARE THERE
WAYS TO TRUNCATE?
THAT PROCESS TO GET THE WAIT
TIME DOWN [inaudible]
SO.
THERE'S THERE'S A LIMIT TO WHAT
YOU CAN DO WITH THE RE DIRECTED
RESOURCES AND IT'S ALL INTERNAL
STAFF AT THE MOMENT.
SO ONE OF THE ADVANTAGES THAT I
SEE WITH THIS OFFICE IS THAT
IT'S A PARTNERING WITH WITH
EXTERNAL WITH PRIVATE SECTOR --
THE US DIGITAL SERVICES BRINGS
AND PEOPLE FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR ON TO OUR FOUR YEAR
STANDS -- THAN A MAN.
THEY THEY DO GOVERNMENT SERVICE
THEY BRING IN SOME IDEAS ABOUT
HOW TO IMPROVE HOW IT OPERATES
WORK ON PARTICULAR PROJECTS THAN
THEY GO BACK TO THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
I THINK LIKEWISE THIS OFFICE
NEEDS TO HAVE THAT THAT ABILITY
AND THAT'S PART OF WHAT FUNDING
ALLOWS YOU TO DO.
WHICH WERE NOT ABLE TO DO IT
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES --
IT'S ALSO A MUCH BROADER REACH
SO.
YOU KNOW HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES IS THE LARGEST AGENCY
IN THE STATE THERE'S THERE'S
RESOURCES AVAILABLE THAT I WAS
ABLE TO TO RE DIRECT. FOR AS
SMALL OFFICE -- BUT THAT'S
THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE AND ALL
AGENCIES ARE ALL DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND SO THIS
OFFICE ALLOWS FOR THE ONES THAT
CAN'T DO THAT SORT OF THING TO
ACTUALLY HAVE.
NOW THE ABILITY TO TO DO THIS
TYPE OF WORK.
HAVING IT AT GOVERNOR
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS ALLOWS
IT TO BE IN A PLACE WHERE IT
CENTRAL.
WHERE IT ALSO HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO PUSH THIS?
SO FRIENDS AT HHS.
I WAS ABLE TO DO THAT BECAUSE I
I WAS SECRETARY OF THE AGENCY
AND I HAD PARTICULAR DEPARTMENTS
AND THERE WAS BY AND OVER ABOUT
A FOUR YEAR PERIOD.
AND HOW THIS WORK.
I THINK THIS HAS TO BE SCALED UP
FASTER THAN THAT.
THAT WAS A A PROCESS THAT WE
WENT THROUGH THAT WAS REALLY A
PROTOTYPING PROCESS OF HOW.
TO LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS IN
THE FOUR YEARS AND WILL APPLY
THOSE AS WE START TO BRING THIS
OFFICE OUT.
YOU REFERRED TO TO DO THIS.
UP AND YOU KNOW AS AS YOU SPOKE.
AT IT IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT YOU MEAN
BY TO DO THIS -- AND THAT'S WHY
WE NEED A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES
LIKE RIGHT AND THAT AND THAT'S
WHY WITH STIRRED MIGHT QUESTION
WHICH IS.
THERE ARE GOOD EXAMPLES -- AND
IS THIS AN ATTEMPT TO COME IN
AND SAY WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
ACROSS THE BOARD IN EVERY SINGLE
DEPARTMENT.
QUESTION IS WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO AND I THINK TO SENATOR
UMBERG'S QUESTION IS.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO IN ALL
THE DEPARTMENTS ARE YOU GOING TO
BE IN A POSITION TO SAY
[inaudible]
YES.
THIS IS THE DECISION OF WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO I I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE THIS IS.
THAT'S EXPECTED AND ARE YOU
GOING TO MANDATE SOMETHING.
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THIS AGENCIES
AND ALL THE DEPARTMENTS IT'S
IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
MANDATE TO THEIR SO THERE ARE A
COUPLE THINGS WERE WE'RE GOING
TO MANDATE THE TRAINING SO THAT
WE HAVE PEOPLE AT THE THE SENIOR
LEVELS THAT UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS.
ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE.
SO THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THE THE
APPROACHES.
SO THAT THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT
WHAT'S POSSIBLE SO THAT'S THAT'S
THE FIRST MANDATE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE.
I THINK THE ONE COMMONALITY THAT
WILL BE THERE THROUGH ALL OF THE
PROJECTS.
IS A FOCUS ON THE END USER
WHETHER THAT STATE STAFF IN SOME
INSTANCES WHETHER IT MY ANSWER
RECEIVING SERVICES.
WHETHER IT'S THE GENERAL PUBLIC --
THE TRYING TO REGISTER CARS OR
WHATEVER THEY'RE TRYING TO DO --
THERE'S GOING TO BE A FOCUS ON
THE END USER WHICH ISN'T THERE
AND IN MOST AREAS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW AND
HONESTLY IN MOST AREAS OF
GOVERNMENT -- THE ACTUAL
PROJECTS THEMSELVES.
IS GOING TO BE DEPENDENT ON WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE SO IT COULD BE
SOMETHING LIKE TAKING DATA FROM.
BROWN'S MATCHING IT UP FIGURE
OUT OVERLAPS AND HOW DO YOU PUSH.
THE IMPROVEMENTS IN THE PROGRAMS --
AND THAT'S GONNA THAT -- WICK
CAL FRESH EXAMPLE IT CAN BE
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS SO YOU KNOW
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU GO THROUGH
AT AN APPROVAL PROCESS.
OR AT A PARTICULAR ISSUE AND
THAT CAN GO ACROSS MULTIPLE
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT THAT CAN GO
ACROSS THE COUNTY AND STATE.
GET IN THERE AND ACTUALLY START
TO TO TEAR IT APART AND WHAT'S
WHAT'S NEEDED SO FOR INSTANCE WE
PARTNERED UP WITH RESEARCH
UNIVERSITIES TO STREAMLINE
ACCESS TO DATA.
SO BEFORE WE DID THIS THERE WERE
MULTIPLE APPLICATIONS FOR HHS.
INSTEAD NOW THERE'S A COMMON
APPLICATION WE WENT THROUGH AND
SAID WHAT DO WE ACTUALLY NEED TO
BE ASKING.
FOR AND IF IF WE HAVE THINGS
THAT AREN'T STATUTORILY REQUIRED
WHY ARE WE DOING THAT. TO JUST
PULL IT OUT WHAT ARE THE
COMMONALITIES SO THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO GO ACROSS.
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS ANYHOW ONE
ACCESS POINT.
SO THOSE ARE THINGS LIKE THAT
WEBSITE REDESIGNS -- YEAH THE
WEBSITES OF THE MOST STATE
DEPARTMENTS ARE FAIRLY DIFFICULT
TO NAVIGATE -- QUITE OFTEN YOU
DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION THAT
ASA MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC YOU
REALLY WANT WHEN YOU LOOK AT A
WEBSITE.
INSTEAD YOU YOU HAVE
DESCRIPTIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT
YOU HAVE BIO'S OF THE DIRECTOR.
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT YOU KNOW
IT IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT FROM
A PRIVATE CITIZEN VIEWPOINT YOU
REALLY DON'T CARE.
YOU REALLY JUST YOU WANT.
ACCESS TO A PARTICULAR SERVICE
YOU WANT SOMETHING DONE AND
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS
THAT THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
AND START TO SHIFT.
HOW WE WE INTERACT WITH THE
GENERAL PUBLIC?
JUST ONE MORE QUESTION -- YOU
MENTIONED THIS BUT YOU CAN.
GET INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE.
THIS COMPLEMENTARY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY I MEAN
WE ALREADY HAVE.
THE TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT.
HOW IS THIS DIFFERENT?
AND WHY DO WE HAVE TO HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT -- THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY IS IS REALLY FOCUSED
ON TECHNOLOGY THIS THIS IS NOT
NECESSARILY FOCUSED ON
TECHNOLOGY I GUESS A LOT OF IT
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT A LOT OF ITS
FOCUSING ON END USERS.
AND CHANGING THE WAY THAT WE
VIEW OUR SOLUTIONS.
NOW THE SOLUTION MAY HAVE SOME
IT COMPONENT TO IT BUT IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE THE I. T. -- THE
TRAINING IS FOCUSED ON
EXECUTIVES AND ON PROGRAM STAFF
NOT ON THE IT.
COMMUNITY.
THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
FOCUSES ON THE I. T. COMMUNITY
SO THEY PROVIDE TRAINING FOR FOR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY FOLKS.
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR COMMON
PLATFORM SO -- FOR INSTANCE WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
THE MACRO -- WEB PAGE FOR THE
STATE OR YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT -- SOMETHING LIKE A MACRO
PAYMENT.
STANDARD FOR THE STATE.
THAT'S BEEN IMPLEMENTED BY AN I.
T. PROJECT.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY DOES
NOW WILL CONTINUE TO DO --
OVERSIGHT OF LARGE IT PROJECTS
IS IN THE PURVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY THIS
OFFICE WOULD NOT BE INVOLVED IN
IN LARGE IT PROCUREMENTS. SEVEN
WHEN IT WHEN YOU'RE DONE.
YEAH -- QUESTION -- AND THESE
THE GOING BACK TO THE ISSUE OF
THE FIFTY POSITIONS -- ONE
QUESTION WAS HOW WE HOW DO YOU
EXPECT HIGHER THAT MANY BUT HOW
DID YOU COME UP WITH. FIFTY
POSITIONS THAT THAT WOULD BE.
THE APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF STAFF.
IT WAS JUST THE INITIAL ESTIMATE
YOU KNOW IT WE WENT THROUGH AND
LOOKED AT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFF THAT WE WOULD NEED TO RUN
AN OFFICE LIKE THIS.
AND THEN WE STARTED LOOKING AT
THE TYPES OF FUNCTIONS
FUNCTIONAL STAFF THAT WE WOULD
NEED BUILT IN THE DIFFERENT
AREAS.
AND WE WOULD NEED MULTIPLE
PROJECTS GOING AT THE SAME TIME
SO THAT'S NO IT'S NOT.
IF YOU HAVE YOUR STAFF YOU DO
FOR YOUR PROJECTS IF YOU HAVE
MORE STAFF YOU DO MORE PROJECT.
AND IF.
WHAT WE SEEN WITH THESE OFFICES
IN OTHER AREAS IS THAT THEY
SCALE OUT?
SO THEY START OUT AT A CERTAIN
LEVEL AND THEY THEY GENERALLY
GROW PRETTY QUICKLY AS MORE
DEPARTMENTS.
WANT TO HAVE THE THE SERVICES
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING THE
INSIGHTS OF THEIR PROVIDING.
AS THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE
EITHER IF IT'S A STATE THE
LEGISLATURE OR THE US CONGRESS.
AS THEY HAVE THEIR EXPECTATIONS
ABOUT WHAT THOSE INTERACTION
SHOULD LOOK LIKE AND WHAT THE
VARIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS THINK
SHOULD BE DONE [inaudible]
PUBLIC.
THE NUMBER SO NOT NOT TO BELABOR
THIS BUT I SHARE SOME OF YOUR
CONCERNS -- SENATOR ALSO.
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK THIS
OFFICE NEED BE IN EXISTENCE?
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE THE END
DATE FOR THE THE OFFICE SAYS
WHAT I DO SEE IS THAT AS A AS
THE TRAINING CONTINUES.
THAT THE THEY'RE GONNA BE MORE
EXECUTIVES AND MORE SUPERVISORS
THAT UNDERSTAND THE APPROACHES --
AS A FEW MORE PROJECTS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH DEPARTMENTS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE MORE PEOPLE
THAT UNDERSTAND HOW TO DO THESE
TYPES OF THINGS.
AND SO I THINK THAT THE THE TYPE
OF WORK THAT THE OFFICE IS DOING
IS GOING TO SHIFT.
AS AS YOU DO THAT SO SOME OF THE
EASIER STUFF THAT ILL ENGAGE IN
AT THE BEGINNING.
WILL BE TAKEN OVER BY
DEPARTMENTS AS THEY GET THE
SKILL SETS TO TO DO THAT ON
THEIR OWN AND THEN THE MORE
DIFFICULT PROJECTS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO COME INTO THE OFFICE.
SO I'M NOT SEEING A PARTICULAR
AND DAVE BUT I AM SAYING THAT
THE THE MISSION.
ALL THE TYPES OF PROJECTS TO
MISSIONAL SAYS SOME OF THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS.
WILL CHANGE OVER TIME SO.
INSTRUCTOR WILL MEAN YOU YOU
HAVE A VISION AND WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT VISION
IS IT'S KINDA LIKE JELLO RIGHT
NOW FOR ME -- AND I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT.
YOU CAN YOU AT SOME POINT IN
TIME.
YOU DO IN THE NEXT YEAR HAVE A
GOAL TO WORK YOURSELF OUT OF
EXISTENCE I'M IN THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION.
WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT THAT TO
THE EXTENT YOU WANT TO CREATE A
CULTURAL CHANGE AT SOME POINT
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO CREATE THE
CULTURAL CHANGES LIKE THE OFFICE
OF GOOD GOVERNMENT IT SHOULD BE
I WOULD THINK THAT EVERY ENTITY
EVERY AGENCY WOULD WANT.
TO ENGAGE IN DIGITAL INNOVATION
AND THAT.
THAT WOULD.
MEAN THAT AT SOME POINT.
EVERYBODY'S DOING IT AND SO YOU
THIS OFFICE WOULD NOT NEED TO
EXIST IS THAT.
AM I WRONG ABOUT THAT.
I THINK THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN
AND AND THE REASON I SAY THAT IS
THAT EXPECTATIONS ALSO CHANGE
OVER TIME.
AND SO TEN YEARS FROM NOW WHAT
WE THOUGHT WAS GOOD TODAY MAY
NOT BE OKAY.
IN A DECADE -- SO THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY I I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING ESPECIALLY THE
TRAIN UP THE WORK FORCE AS YOU
GET MORE PEOPLE THAT UNDERSTAND
THAT.
THE THAT'S WHY I SAY THE THE
PROJECT TYPES I THINK SHIFT.
AND THAT THE MORE COMPLEX THINGS
CONTINUE TO TO COME TO THIS
OFFICE AND THE EASIER THINGS.
ARE JUST TAKING CARE OF BY THE
THE PEOPLE THAT NOW BOUGHT INTO
THE APPROACH IS WHAT WILL BE
ANXIOUS TO SEE.
WHAT WHAT PRODUCTS ARE PRODUCED
WHAT METRICS ARE PROVIDED?
ALL ALL ALL THOSE THINGS -- ONE
LAST SUGGESTION IS THAT TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT.
BEING USER CENTRIC.
AND I'VE ASKED THIS QUESTION OF
OTHERS IS THAT THAT WHOEVER IS
IN CHARGE OF THAT PARTICULAR
ASPECT THAT THEY ACTUALLY USE
THE SYSTEM.
SO.
IF IT'S DMV THAT SOMEBODY
ACTUALLY TRIES TO MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT WITH DMV.
I'VE TRIED TO DO THAT VERY HARD --
LOT OF ARE INTO YOUR POINT LOT
OF OUR POINTS OF ACCESS FOR
CONSUMERS ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE THE ONE EXCEPTION THAT
IS.
PAYING YOUR TAXES YOU CAN DO
THAT RELATIVELY EASILY.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO FOR EXAMPLE
MAKE APPOINTMENT DMV KIND OF SO
JUST JUST A SUGGESTION BECAUSE
NEXT YEAR WILL ASK OR BY THE WAY
DID YOU.
ACTUALLY USE WHATEVER.
AND SYSTEM YOU'VE CREATED A GOOD
SUGGESTION.
NO I AND I WOULD JUST BE PETE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I STILL
NEED.
IS THE THE COLLABORATION OR THE
YOU MENTIONED THIS IS AS OPEN
THAT'S WHAT THE LEGISLATURE BUT
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE A LOT
CLEARER -- TO GIVE US THE THE
COMFORT LEVEL -- I THINK STILL
THE QUESTION OF YOUR
COORDINATION OR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE IT.
DEPARTMENT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND HOW THIS IS SUPPOSED TO DO.
PRODUCE SOMETHING BETTER FOR A
FOR THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
TWO YEARS.
WE NEED MORE OF THAT BUT I
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT.
WE'RE LOOKING WE'RE GOING TO TRY
TO LOOK OUT OF THE BOX HERE THAT
WE'RE NOT STUCK IN ONE PLACE.
I THINK IT'S JUST A MATTER OF IF
THAT'S THE CASE AND MAYBE WE
DON'T NEED.
PEOPLE IN ANOTHER DEPARTMENT WHO
COULD MOVE INTO THIS DEPARTMENT
OR YOU KNOW I MEAN I THINK
THERE'S ALSO A QUESTION OF
EFFICIENCY RATHER THAN JUST.
HIS FIFTY MORE PEOPLE AND LET'S
GO OUT AND DO WHATEVER WE CAN SO.
I GREATLY APPRECIATE -- THE
IDEAS THAT YOU PRESENTED AND
WHAT YOU WANT TO COMPETITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU --
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE ON THIS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR ROBB GROWS CLOSER WITH
AMAZON WEB SERVICES -- SECRETARY
WILKENING USE THE TERM AND USER
AND FOR OUR CULTURE THAT MEANS
THE CUSTOMER AMAZON IS ONE OF
THE WORLD'S MOST CUSTOMER
FOCUSED CUSTOMER OBSESSED
COMPANIES IT AROUND.
AND WE VIEW THIS PROPOSAL
THROUGH THAT LANDS THAT THIS IS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
MINISTRATIONS INCREASING THAT
COMMITMENT TO CUSTOMERS.
I THINK THAT THERE'S DEFINITELY
A GAP WHEN IT COMES TO CUSTOMERS
INTERACTING WITH GOVERNMENT.
AND TO HAVE AN OFFICE LIKE THIS
THAT HAVE THE EXPERTISE AND THAT
ADDITIONAL LAYER TO ASSIST WITH
THAT WOULD GREATLY GO FORWARD IN
PROVIDING THE SERVICES TO OUR
CITIZENS AND SO IT'S WITH THAT
LENS THAT WE SUPPORT.
THIS ITEM AND ALSO GIVEN
SECRETARY LOOKING AND IS THE
POST THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RENTER CENTER MY NAME'S PETER
KELLY I'M.
PRIVATE CITIZEN BUT I USED TO
WORK IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN THIS SPACE.
AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS.
GOVERNMENT HAS TWO MODELS FOR
HOW IT CHANGES.
THE FIRST IS TELLING PEOPLE HOW
TO DO IT FROM THE OUTSIDE.
AND THE SECOND IS SHOWING HOW TO
DO IT FROM THE INSIDE IT'S
PARTNER.
WE HAVE FAR TOO MUCH OF THE
FIRST.
AND NOT ENOUGH OF A SECOND.
THIS PROPOSAL SEEMS TO BE
FOCUSING ON THE SECOND.
IT LOOKS AT MODELS THE U. K.
GOVERNMENT FULL SERVICE AND THE
USPS WHICH HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
ADOPTED THIS APPROACH.
OVER THE LAST FOUR TO SEVEN
YEARS.
IT DOES NOT LOOK LIKE MODELS
WHERE IT IS DEFINING HOW DO
SOMETHING.
IT IS A MODEL THAT'S COMING FROM
THE INSIDE AND CHUCKLE HOW DO AS
A PARTNER.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF THAT.
THIS AGENCY HAS PROVEN LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS THAT IT HAS MADE
THIS MODEL.
AFFECTED WITHIN SIEGES OF ESSAY
AND IT SHOULD BE LOOKED OUT
ACROSS THE GOVERNMENT.
TOP COVER IS REQUIRED TO MAKE
THESE SORTS OF CHANGE THE
SOMETHING SECRETARY HAS DONE
SOMETHING TO GO OFF HAS DONE.
BUT IT IS VERY DIFFICULT IT IS
SOMETHING IT HAS TO BE
CONTINUOUSLY REINFORCED.
NOT.
CAN NOT FADE AWAY.
FOCUSING ON THE CENTER THE
SERVICE AT THE CENTER OF
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE A STATE
OFFERING PROCEDURE BUT IT IS NOT.
IT'S NOT HOW WE OPERATE.
I LONG ADVOCATED THAT DEPARTMENT
EXECUTIVES USE THE FRONT DOOR
FOR EARNED SERVICES CENTER LIKE
YOU SAID.
BUT THEY GENERALLY DO NOT WHAT
I'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS IS THAT.
HELPING YOU WITH SERVICE AGENCY
DEPARTMENT EXECUTIVES DO THIS
NOW MORE THAN EVER HAVE IN THE
PAST.
GOVERNMENT OFTEN FALLS BACK ON
THIS IS THE WAY WE'VE ALWAYS
DONE IT.
STAFF MEET YOUR REWARD FOR
ASKING WHY WE TALK ABOUT TAKE
INTELLIGENT RISKS BUT EVEN AS HE
RECOGNIZED THIS IS REQUIRED.
IT IS NOT DONE WE STILL ACT
PUNITIVE LEE WHEN GOVERNOR
EXECUTIVES ATTEMPT TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS.
THERE IS NO REWARD FOR
INTELLIGENT RISK TAKING. TEN
YEARS AGO WHEN PEOPLE ASKED
ABOUT USING THESE DEVICES
PROVIDE CITIZENS SERVICES
EVERYONE LAUGHED.
THAT WAS TWO YEARS AFTER THE
IPHONE WAS RELEASED TODAY WE'RE
PLAYING CATCH UP WE'RE NOT
PROVIDING THE SERVICES THAT WE
NEED.
AND WE ARE AT A SIGNIFICANT
DISADVANTAGE AS A RESULT.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY NOT ON HOW WE
SERVE CITIZENS BECAUSE WE DON'T
COORDINATE ACROSS DEPARTMENTS IN
A WAY THAT WAS THE CITIZEN AT
THE CENTER.
DEPARTMENTS WANT TO IMPROVE.
BUT DAY.
IF THEY'RE NOT TOLD THAT THEY
CAN MAKE THESE IMPROVEMENTS HAVE
A CHALLENGE COR NAY ACROSS
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS BUT
SECRETARY AND HIS STAFF OF SHOWN
WITHIN HHS THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
IS THAT PROVIDE THAT TOP COVER
IN BRINGING DEPARTMENTS TOGETHER
DO IN FACT IMPROVE THE SERVICES --
I WOULD HIGHLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LOOK MORE INTO THE U. K. GDS AND
THE USPS MODELS.
I THINK THEY ARE AN EXCELLENT
MODEL THE CALIFORNIA SHUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
YOU MORE PUBLIC COMMENT. THREE
NINE SENATOR STEVEN OPENING.
YES YES EVER MADE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SECRETARY WILKENING WE
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR TIME AND ALL
YOUR ANSWERS.
WE OR DID YOU.
WILL GET YOU ANOTHER TIME
[inaudible]
JUST KIDDING.
OKAY WE ARE GOING TO ISSUE.
SIXTEEN CENSUS OUT REACH
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
OKAY -- GO AHEAD INTRODUCED.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR UMBERG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR INVITING ME HERE -- TO
TESTIFY ABOUT THE EFFORTS FOR
THE COMPLETE COUNTY OFFICE SINCE
IT'S TWENTY TWENTY I DO THIS
GUITAR AGAIN AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA.
COUNTY CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY
OFFICE.
DID YOU KNOW THE DECENNIAL
CENSUS IS LESS THAN A YEAR AWAY.
AND IT IS THE LARGEST FEDERAL
OPERATION OUTSIDE GOING TO WAR.
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AND
COMMITMENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE LEGISLATURE IN
FUNDING OUR STATE WHITE EFFORTS
TO DATE FOR THE COMPLETE COUNT
OFFICE.
AND I WANT TO REMIND FOLKS THAT
THE MISSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT OFFICE IS TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIANS GET
THEIR FAIR SHARE OUR FAIR SHARE
OF FEDERAL RESOURCES.
AND FEDERAL CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATION BY ENCOURAGING A
FULL PARTICIPATION OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN THE DECENNIAL
CENSUS.
OF THE JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL
INCLUDES FIFTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO AUGMENT
ACTIVITIES BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT OFFICE TO FURTHER
ENHANCE OUR EFFORTS CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY TO ENSURE A FULL AND
ACCURATE COUNT.
OF OUR ENTIRE POPULATION.
CENTER UMBERG.
WE PLAN TO USE THE SYNERGY.
OF THE INTERFACE WHAT ARE HARD
TO GET OUT. TO HAVE AN EFFECTIVE
DIALOGUE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO LEVERAGE OUR
PARTNERS OUT THERE SO I JUST
WANT TO THROW THAT ONE IN SHE'S
PAYMENT TO AND I'M THINKING.
HE IS REALLY GETTING THAT THAN
TO FIND A USE FOR THOSE WORDS.
KIDS ARE OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT
FOCUS ON THE HARDEST ACCOUNT FOR
THOSE WHO BEEN HISTORICALLY
UNDERCOUNTED IN THE SENSE.
ACTUALLY FIFTY MILLION WOULD BE
PROVIDED TO AUGMENT OUTREACH
EFFORTS LIKE ME BASS
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS THE
OUTREACH AND PUBLIC RELATIONS
MEDIA CAMPAIGN CONTRACTORS.
SPECIFICALLY OUR REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE SUPPORT
FOR THE NON RESPONSE FOLLOW UP
IT'S CALLED OUR FOOD WE USE
ACRONYMS A LOT THE NERVE FOR
PERIOD.
WHICH BEGINS IN APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY AND CONTINUES THROUGH
LATE JULY.
NERF WHO IS THE US CENSUS
BUREAU'S EFFORT THAT THE ON THE
GROUND TO KNOCK ON DOORS OF
HOUSEHOLDS WHO HAVE NOT YET
RESPONDED.
THE ORIGINAL ALLOCATION WAS FOR
TWENTY TWO POINT.
NINE AND THAT'S GONNA BE
AUGMENTED BY TEN MILLION TO
REACH COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THAT
LOW RESPONSE RATE AS THE
ENUMERATION CONTINUES.
ADDITIONAL WORD OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WORDS TO FILL IN THE GAPS TO
BE RESPONSIVE TO AREAS THAT NEED
FURTHER OUT REACH.
THE CURRENT BUDGET PROVIDED FOUR
POINT ZERO FIVE MILLION WHICH WE
AWARDED ACTUALLY LAST WEEK AND
THAT WILL BE AUGMENTED BY
APPROXIMATELY ANOTHER FIVE POINT
NINE FIVE MILLION. TO FURTHER
TARGETED OUT REACHED HARD COUNT
POPULATIONS AND FORMAL
POPULATIONS.
IN ADDITION THE OUTREACH AND
PUBLIC RELATIONS OR WHAT WE CALL
THE MEDIA CAMPAIGN IT'S OUR AIR
GAME WILL BE AUGMENTED BY THIRTY
MILLION. TO ACHIEVE STATEWIDE
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN THAT IS MULTI
LINGUAL CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
AND THAT ENGAGES LOCAL ETHNIC
MEDIA. TO BUILD OUR BASE OF
TRUST THE MESSENGERS BECAUSE WE
KNOW CALIFORNIANS NO
CALIFORNIA'S BEST.
IN SOME THAT BRINGS THE TOTAL
OUT REACH FUNDING BETWEEN THE
CURRENT.
AND NEXT FISCAL YEAR TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS STATEWIDE.
AN ADDITIONAL ITEM IN THIS
PROPOSAL IS THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING AND POPULATION SAMPLE
ENUMERATION WE CALLED GYPSY FOR
SHORT.
OF THE FOUR MILLION FUNDING WILL
BE SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING POPULATION SAMPLE
ENUMERATION PLYMOUTH WILL WHICH
IS A STUDY BEING CONDUCTED.
BY THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
DEMOGRAPHIC RESEARCH UNIT.
THE STUDY WILL PROVIDE SEVERAL
IMPORTANT DATA SETS FOLLOWING
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
THIS INCLUDES HELPING TO
IDENTIFY HOW SUCCESSFUL WERE WE
IN ACHIEVING A FULL AND COMPLETE
COUNCIL LOOKING FOR SOME OF
THOSE MEASURABLES THOSE METRICS
WHAT BARRIERS EXISTED THAT
BLOCKED OUR OUTRAGE FROM BEING
SUCCESSFUL.
WE MIGHT EVEN HEAR SOME STUFF
EFFORTS IN THAT AND HOW CAN WE
BEST PREPARE FOR THE TWENTY
THIRTY CENTS.
SO THAT LAST POINT IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETELY OFF HELD OFFICE IS
WORKING DILIGENTLY NOT ONLY TO
REPAIR FOR SUCH A TWENTY TWENTY
BUT WE'RE ALSO WORKING TO
ESTABLISH A WELL DOCUMENTED
REPEATABLE OPERATION AND
STRATEGY.
THAT WILL SERVE THE STATE AGAIN
420-30 WE'VE HAD TO REBUILD
EVERYTHING EVEN THOUGH I DID THE
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND
TEN WE BUILT FROM SCRATCH WITH
THE WITH THE GREAT HELP OF
GOVERNMENT OPS.
OPERATIONS.
EIGHT PREPARING FOR THE NEXT
CYCLE BEYONCE.
I'M JUST IN CLOSING A FINAL NOTE
THIS WEEK ACROSS THE STATE --
COMMUNITIES ARE HOLDING THEIR
KICKOFFS ESSENCES TWENTY TO
TWENTY A DAY IS APRIL FIRST JUST
A YEAR AWAY.
WE KNOW THAT THAT'S A TWENTY
WILL BE CHALLENGING BUT MY TEAM
AND OUR PARTNERS ACROSS THE
STATE.
ARE SAN PREPARED INNER PREPARING
RIGHT NOW -- TO ENGAGE AND DO
THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
TO ENSURE COMPLETE COUNT.
THEY SAY IT TAKES A VILLAGE BUT
I'M HERE TO SAY IT TAKES ALL
VILLAGES AND COMMUNITIES OF
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE A COMPLETE
AND ACCURATE COUNT.
I WITH THAT WERE ABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DO LIKE TO GO AHEAD.
AND JUST HOW ARE FROM THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY I
JUST IN HERE SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND ECHO
EVERYTHING DIRECTOR.
JUST [inaudible]
GREAT [inaudible]
LA YOU.
I WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL AND JUST KNOW
THAT IT'S CONSISTENT WITH PAST
LEGISLATIVE ACTION IN THIS AREA.
YOUR FRIENDS.
NOTHING.
OKAY SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU DIRECTORS THE DOGGIE.
WE CAN'T UNDERESTIMATE PORTENTS
OF YOUR JOB IN OUR EFFORT HERE.
IT'S CRITICAL CALIFORNIA --
COUPLE THINGS TERMS OF METRICS --
IT AND WE DON'T NEED TO DO IT
TODAY BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE
USEFUL FOR US TO SEE NO DOUBT
YOU HAVE THEM YOU KNOW HERE'S
YOU KNOW HOW MANY.
PEOPLE WE INTENDED TOUCH THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA HERE'S HOW MANY P.
AND HERE'S HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO
IT HERE SO MANY PEOPLE WE INTEND
TO TOUCH THROUGH.
COULD MEET WHATEVER IT MAY BE --
ONE AREA OF CONCERN.
MANY YEARS OF CONCERT BUT ONE
PARTICULAR AREA OF CONCERN.
IT WITH IS IS WITH RESPECT -- TO
SORT OF A A COUNTER -- COUNTER
INSURGENCY APPROACH IN THE SENSE
THAT.
I WOULD EXPECT THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE FAKE NEWS POINT IN
TERMS OF FAKE NEWS WITH RESPECT.
TO FOR EXAMPLE ICE AGENTS
APPEARING AT SOMEONE'S DOOR AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF FILLING OUT THE
QUESTIONNAIRE IF THE CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION SHOULD BE ON THE ON THE
QUESTIONNAIRE.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO TO TO
ADDRESS THAT ARE WE PREPARED TO
ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE IT SEEMS
THAT GOES VIRAL THAT'S THAT'S
GOING?
TO RATED AN ATMOSPHERE OF
INTIMIDATION IF IT DOESN'T
ALREADY EXIST.
YES SO IN OUR OUTREACH AND
PUBLIC RELATIONS MEDIA OR P.
WHICH WE JUST LET AND HAD A
BIGGER CONFERENCE LAST WEEK WE
PUT THAT IN THERE IN TERMS OF
MANAGING MISINFORMATION
DISINFORMATION.
AND A WHAT WE CALL CRISIS
COMMUNICATIONS OF WE REALLY LOOK
AT THIS SIMILAR TO HOW YOU RUN A
CAMPAIGN IS IT'S MISINFORMATION
IS AT OPS RESEARCH WHAT ARE THEY
GOING TO BE DOING.
THAT MAY DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
COMING OUT.
BUT IN ADDITION TO LIKE IF YOU
THINK IT AS A CAMPAIGN WISE WERE
LAYING THE GROUNDWORK RIGHT NOW
THROUGH ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY
BASED GROUPS IS WE'RE DOING THIS
NETWORK ON THE GROUND.
SO EVEN FURTHER THAN IF YOU
WOULD IN A IN A RUNNING FOR
OFFICE WE'RE PUTTING THIS THE
SORT OF BUTTON BLANKET MATCH.
PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
TRUTH IS TO UNDERSTAND HOW IT
AFFECTS OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT
CAN HELP US ONE MONITOR SOME OF
MISINFORMATION BECAUSE SOME OF
THAT HAPPENS.
DOWN ON THE GROUND AND THAT CAN
SPEAK TRUTH TO IT AND THAT CAN
HOPEFULLY QUELCH AND PUSH OUT
ANYTHING THAT GOES VIRAL WE WANT
TO GO VIRAL WITH THE RIGHT
THINGS.
AND THE RIGHT MESSAGES SO THAT'S
REALLY WHY WITH OUR GROUND GAME
AN AIR GAME ARE REALLY
INTEGRATED -- AND MY WERE
ACTIVATING NOW OF THE MESSAGING
WE HAVE NOW IS MORE ABOUT
EDUCATING WERE REALLY BUILDING.
THAT STRENGTHEN ALMOST PLATOON
MY PLATOON -- THROUGHOUT OUR OUR
OUR STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN COMBAT ANY OF THAT THAT
COMES UP BUT YOU KNOW WHO KNOWS
WHAT THEY'LL COME UP WITH BUT WE
STAND READY.
I CAN ADD TO THAT JUST A LITTLE
BIT FROM MORE TECHNICAL
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE ONE THING
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PROGRAM
THERE ESTABLISH HERE'S CREAM
VERY NIMBLE PROCESS SO THAT IF
WE NEED TO REMOVE RESOURCES
QUICKLY TO COMBAT THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS WE CAN.
SO WE HAVE OUR CONTRACTOR
PARTNERS THAT ARE OUT THERE WE
ARE WE HAVE REGULAR CHECK INS
WITH THEM WE ALSO SET ASIDE
FUNDING AND THEN WEEK AND AS WE
HEAR THOSE THINGS DEVELOP ON THE
GROUND.
WE CAN THEN DIRECT THEM TO MOVE
RESOURCES TO COMBAT THOSE
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS AS THEY
SHOULD IF THEY SHOULD
MATERIALIZE SO. ONE THING THAT
WERE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
EVERYTHING WE DO -- THAT
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE NEED IN OUR
CONTRACT TO QUICKLY MOVE MONEY
TO THOSE AREAS WE HAVE THOSE
TYPES OF CONCERNS SO.
WHEN A POINT THAT OUT?
SO BUT LET ME AGAIN I COMMEND
YOUR EFFORTS -- AGAIN WE CAN'T.
OVER EMPHASIZE ITS IMPORTANCE IS
THE UNIQUE SITUATION WHERE WE
HAVE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHO IS.
WHETHER STATED OR UNSTATED IS
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THE
CALIFORNIA HAS AN UNDERCOUNT IN
A STATE GOVERNMENT THAT IS
VITALLY INTERESTED IN MAKING
SURE WE GET AN ACCURATE COUNT SO.
WE WISH YOU WELL -- I HAVE A A
FEW QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU --
STARTED TO DO.
AND THE THING THERE'S ANY ISSUES
ABOUT HOW CRITICAL AND AND HOME
POINT.
OF MANY MANY CALIFORNIANS DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE ACCOUNT
AND THE CENSUS TO OUR WELL BEING
AND IN THE STATE.
BUT IF YOU COULD -- IN TERMS OF
THE HARD TO COUNT.
OF POPULATION AND YOU KNOW
FAMILIES.
GIVE US A SENSE OF WHAT WHO THAT
IS.
AND HOW DOES YOUR HOW DOES A
PROPOSAL FOR THE YOU KNOW THE
BUDGET.
ADDRESS.
THE HARD TO COUNT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY.
ANYBODY IS NOT HARD TO COUNT
WILL HAVE A PROBLEM WE COULD DO
IT IN A VERY TRADITIONAL WAY NO
BIG DEAL.
BUT IT'S THE HARD TO COUNT THAT
WERE REALLY.
MUCH MORE FOCUSED ON SO.
THAT IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE
BUDGET AND MY STRATEGY.
SO I ALWAYS SAY I'M FILIPINO
AMERICAN BUT I'M REALLY NOT HARD
TO COUNT SO I HOPE NOT TO SEE
ANY OF OUR STATES OUTREACH
EFFORTS ARE EFFORTS AND ALL OF
US HERE WILL OBVIOUSLY FILL IT
OUT.
OUR EFFORT TO REALLY FOCUS ON
WHAT WE LOOK AT THOSE HARD TO
HELP POPULATIONS WE ALSO LOOK AT
HARD TO COUNT CENSUS TRACKS OR
GEOGRAPHY.
BECAUSE THE THE U. S. CENSUS IS
EIGHT ADDRESS BASED ENUMERATION
WE KIND OF CUT IT BOTH WAYS SO
WE HAVE HARD TO COUNT --
DEMOGRAPHIC POPULATIONS WHICH I
CALL A BORDER POPULATIONS WHICH
INCLUDE YOU KNOW THE ASIAN
AMERICAN LATINOS AFRICAN
AMERICANS MIDDLE EASTERN NORTH
AFRICANS NATIVE AMERICANS YOU
KNOW A PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
UP PEOPLE WITH LOW BROADBAND AS
A WHOLE LIST OF FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT -- WELL CALLED
DEMOGRAPHIC POPULATIONS AND THEN
WE LOOK AT ACROSS THE STATE
WE'VE TAKEN THAT THE FIGHTING IS
WERE DOING I WHICH FOR THE THE
CENSUS.
AND WE HAD YOU SENSE OF DATA TO
ACTUALLY DO THIS EXAMINATION SO
WE LOOK AT GEOGRAPHICALLY AREAS
THAT HAVE VARIABLE SO THAT'S ALL
DATA BASED.
THAT WOULD WOULD ACTUALLY OVERLY
TO PROMOTE THAT THAT THAT PEOPLE
LIVING IN THOSE AREAS WILL BE
HARD TO COUNT. FOR EXAMPLE IN A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY THEY HAVE ONE
OF THEIR KEY FACTORS IS CROWDED
HOUSING UNITS RIGHT BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE DOUBLING UP BECAUSE
RENTS.
AND HOUSING IS SO EXPENSIVE YOU
CAN HAVE THREE OR FOUR FAMILIES
LIVING IN A SINGLE UNIT THE
HOUSE WANT TO DRESS.
SO OVERCROWDING MEANS THAT THAT
ADDRESS WILL GET ONE POSTCARD OR
ONE FORM AND ONE PERSON THAT THE
CALL HAD A THE US CENSUS RECALLS
HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD.
WILL FILL IT OUT BUT IF THE ONLY
FILL OUT FOR ONE OF THE FAMILIES
THEY'VE JUST LOT LOST TWO OF THE
OTHER FAMILIES.
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY IS
ANOTHER FACTOR THAT THAT WE
OVERLAY UP IN THOSE AREAS AND SO
WE LOOK AT THE DENSITY OF PEOPLE
HEARD CROWDED UNITS LIMITED.
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY EDUCATIONAL
FOLKS THAT ARE -- MAYBE PER
RECEIVING PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
LOOKING AT OTHER THINGS LIKE
RENTER'S SO THERE'S A NUMBER WAY
SO WE LOOK AT AND THEN THE WAY
WE DO OUR BUDGET IS WE LOOK AT
WHERE.
AT THREE WAYS WHERE THEY ARE
REGIONAL WE HAVE A REGIONALLY
CBO'S A WE DEDICATED. THIRTY
PLUS ADDITIONAL TEN CENTS FORTY
MILLION OF THE HUNDRED FORTY TO
THAT.
THEN ALSO COUNTIES SO AND
DEDICATED ABOUT THIRTY MILLION --
FOR THEM AS WELL SO IT'S UNDER
SIXTY OR SO THAT WOULD BE FORTY
PLUS I'M DOING ALL THE MATH IN
MY HEAD SORRY.
AND THEN WE DID A STATEWIDE
CBO'S WHICH IS WHO THEY ARE THIS
FIFTEEN DEMOGRAPHIC VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND THEN THE FINAL
KIND OF LEG OF THE STOOL IS HOW
DO WE GET TO THEM IT'S OUR
SECTOR.
OUTRAGE WHICH IS HOW DO YOU GET
TO THEM THROUGH UNIONS THROUGH
SCHOOLS THROUGH -- FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGH EMPLOYERS
OUT I THINK PERSONALLY THAT AT
THIS OF MY THIRD DECENNIAL
CENSUS.
OF THE YOUTH ARE GOING TO BE
VERY KEY IN HELPING US REACH ALL
THOSE POPULATIONS -- AND FRANKLY
I'VE A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD THEY'RE
PRETTY CHARGED UP ABOUT SHE'S
SAYING I CAN'T VOTE BUT I CAN.
AND I CAN GET EVERYBODY TO COUNT
AND SHE GOES TO PUBLIC SCHOOL
HERE IN OF SACRAMENTO.
MANY OF HER -- OF COLLEAGUES FOR
STUDENTS THEIR PARENTS DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH AT HOME AND
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GONNA BE THE
ONES THAT FILL OUT THOSE FORMS.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF I MAY DIDN'T
DO ALL THE NUMBERS WITH THAT BUT
I WANTED TO BREAK IT DOWN INTO.
HOW WE ARE SORT OF BLANKETING
AND DISTURBING THOSE DOLLARS ON
THE GROUND AND THEN WE HAVE THAT
AIR GAME WHICH IS THE THE ETHNIC
MEDIA -- REALLY CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE MESSAGING THAT WILL
COMBINE WITH THE GROUND.
WELL JUST SAID JUST ADD TO THAT
IS EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IS
REALLY TO THAT DATA.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT FUNDING AND
WHERE WE NEED TO DEDICATE
RESOURCES AS OF WE REALLY ARE
TARGETING WHERE THE HEART
IDENTIFIED HER ACCOUNT
POPULATION ARE WE KNOW THAT.
AND WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DEMOGRAPHIC RESEARCH
UNIT AS WELL AS THE DATA THAT WE
GOT FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
INSTANCES.
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE WHO THE
HARD TO COUNTER WHERE THEY ARE
SO THEN WE LOOK TO SPREAD THOSE
RESOURCES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WITH A LOOK TO SPREAD THEM BASED
UPON THE CONCENTRATIONS OF THOSE.
POPULATIONS IN A VERY SERIOUS OF
SOME AREAS HAVE VERY HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF LA FOR EXAMPLE
IS THE HARDEST ACCOUNT COUNTY
RETIRE COUNTRY THE ORDERS COME
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY -- IN FACT
CALIFORNIA'S TEN OF THE TOP
FIFTY HARD DISCOUNT COUNTIES IN
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
IT'S ALL BASED UPON THAT DATA
AND THAT AND THE RESOURCES GOING
OUT ACCORDING TO THAT DATA SO
SOME AREAS WILL GET MORE MONEY
BASED UPON THAT NUMBER PARTY
COUNTY [inaudible]
OF YOU MENTIONED -- LIMITED
ENGLISH COULD YOU GO INTO THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE IN TERMS OF
LANGUAGE ACCESS BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO.
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND SO
MANY DIFFERENT LANGUAGES HOME
EVERYBODY BOASTS ABOUT HOW WE
WERE WE ARE SO WONDERFUL AND
DIVERSE IN THIS STATE -- AND
COMES WITH THAT IS THE LANGUAGE
OF SO MANY CULTURES AND
COMMUNITIES SO.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT WELL I
KNOW THAT -- WILL PROBABLY HAVE
A A LONGER DISCUSSION ABOUT OUR
LANGUAGE ACCESS WERE THE ONLY A
STATE.
ARE THAT HAS ACTUALLY INVESTED
IN OUR HAVING A LANGUAGE ACCESS
AND COMMUNICATIONS STANDARDS.
BUT I WANT TO START REALLY HAVE
TO START THE BASELINE OF WHAT IS
THE US CENSUS BUREAU DOING WITH
THEIR LANGUAGE ACCESS.
OUR BECAUSE THEN THAT ALLOWS US
TO FIGURE OUT OKAY WHAT ARE THE
GAPS AND WHERE TO REFILL IT.
SO.
I THINK WE MENTIONED THAT IT'LL
BE THE FIRST ONLINE CENSUS EVER --
SO WERE NOT ONLY DEALING WITH
LANGUAGE ACCESS BUT COMPUTER
LITERACY AND ACCESS -- TO
ACTUALLY THE ONLINE FORM THE
ONLY FORM WILL BE IN TWELVE
LANGUAGES THOSE TWELVE LANGUAGES
ARE IDENTIFIED FROM.
AMERICAN COMMUNITY SURVEY DATA
THE TOTALING WHICH IS AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL ARE NOT THE
NECESSARILY THE TWELVE LANGUAGES
YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION YOU CAN GET A PAPER
FORM AND AGAIN I'M NOT WITH THE
US CENSUS BUREAU BUT I I KNOW
ENOUGH TO BE DANGEROUS RIGHT.
SO YOU CAN GET A PAPER FORM BUT
IT'S ONLY GONNA BE IN ENGLISH
AND IN SPANISH.
ALSO YOU CAN ACTUALLY CALL TO
GET BACK.
ON THE THIRD WAY THAT THE US
CENSUS BUREAU WANTS US TO TO
KNOW THAT PEOPLE CAN RESPOND.
IS BY TELEPHONE QUESTION
QUESTIONNAIRE ASSIST THE COUNTY
Q. A TITLE FOR CREEK TELEPHONE
QUESTIONNAIRE ASSISTANCE AND
THAT'LL BE IN THOSE SAME TWELVE
LANGUAGES WHERE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY TALK TO SOMEONE ON THE
PHONE.
SO MY EIGHTY THREE YEAR OLD
MOTHER THAT SPEECH FROM REALLY
TAGALOG NOT SO GREAT ON THE IPAD
IF I SIXTEEN HELP SIR SHE GOT TO
CALL.
EIGHTEEN AN EIGHT HER NUMBER SHE
CAN UNDERSTAND THEM HOPEFULLY --
THEY CAN HELP -- INTO CALLING
FILL OUT THE FORM -- SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE DOING IN
ADDITION THEY WILL ALSO DO FIFTY
NINE LANGUAGE GUIDES.
WHICH MEANS -- SO IF MY MOM
CAN'T COLIN MY DAUGHTER CAN PULL
THE LANGUAGE GOTTEN TAGALOG
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T SPEAK
TAGALOG.
UNFORTUNATELY AND SHE CAN KIND
OF FIGURE BRITISH CAN WALK
THROUGH.
AND HELP MY MOTHER -- FILL OUT
THE THE THING SO WE ARE LOOKING
PRIMARILY AT WHAT ARE THEY DOING
AND THEN WE HAVE PULLED THE DATA --
FOR CALIFORNIA IT'S BEEN
INTERESTING TO TRY TO GET DATA
DOWN TO THE GRANULAR LEVEL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT THE U.
S. CENSUS BUREAU IS DOING IS
THEY'RE LOOKING AT HOUSEHOLD
LIMITED ENGLISH.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THE DATA TO
REALLY LOOK AT INDIVIDUALS SO
THAT GIVES US EVEN MORE COVERAGE
AND WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
COMPARE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL I'M
CALLING FOR YOUR HE'S SORRY.
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL ONE OF THOSE
WHAT WHAT'S LACKING SO LET'S SAY
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
A WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE COVERING 98% OF LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT SO WE'LL LOOK
AT THAT DATA WE'LL SEE HOW MANY
LANGUAGES THAT ENTAIL IS THAT
ALL. TWO HUNDRED BLOOM AROUND
TEN OR ELEVEN DOES THAT MATCH
THE TEN OR ELEVEN LANGUAGES THAT
THE U. S. CENSUS VERY DOESN'T
MATCH WHAT WE WANT TO DO HERE AT
THE STATE LEVEL HOW CAN WE FILL
THOSE GAPS THAT'S KIND OF JUST A
AND WE'RE STILL IN.
WE'RE STILL IN DEVELOPMENT --
AND AS WE GET THE DATA WILL BE
ABLE.
TO HELP.
KIND OF DISSECT AND REALLY
TARGET BECAUSE ALL OUR EFFORTS
AS I JUST SINCE OTHER ART DATA
INTENSIVE -- BUT WE ARE WE START
WITH THAT AND THEN WE WORK WITH
OUR PARTNERS TO FIND OUT YOU
KNOW WHAT IS TRUTH.
ON THE GROUND IN TERMS OF WHO
NEEDS THE MOST.
I'LL JUST ADD TO THAT THAT -- WE
HAVE PUT OUT A DRAFT LANGUAGE
AND COMMUNICATION ACCESS
STANDARDS THAT WHERE.
BACK ON THE STAKEHOLDERS WE
PRESENTED AT THE LAST CALIFORNIA
THE COUNT COMMITTEE MEETING --
WE'VE GOTTEN SOME GOOD FEEDBACK
AND WE HOPE TO LACKEY IN
CORPORATE THAT FEEDBACK INTO A
FINAL PRODUCT OFFICE YEP FINAL
PRODUCT IS REALLY GOING TO
DICTATE WHAT OUR PARTNERS ONTHE
GROUND YOU TO FOLLOW -- BY WHAT
IS REQUIRED WHAT'S NOT REQUIRED
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE CONSIDERING AND THAT'S
STILL IN DEVELOPMENT WITH
HOPEFULLY TOWARDS THE END OF
THIS MONTH WILL HAVE ANOTHER.
ITERATION IT MIGHT BE A DRAFT
MAYBE MORE FINAL BUT WILL HAVE
ANOTHER ITERATION HOEFULLY WE
COULD SHARE -- WITH EVERYONE.
I KNOW THEIR EFFORTS IN THE
FOUNDATION OR IN PHILANTHROPY ON
THE PRIVATE SECTOR -- TO ALSO
VERY THEY'RE VERY MOTIVATED AS
WELL -- COULD YOU TALK ABOUT HOW
WE'LL WHAT IS OUR EFFORT TO
COORDINATE HOME SO THAT WE DON'T
DUPLICATE -- ABSOLUTELY WHATEVER
RESOURCES WE HAVE AND USE THEM
TO THEIR MAXIMUM.
SO I CAME ABOARD -- ACTUALLY IN
THE DEMOGRAPHICS RESEARCH UNIT
IN APRIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND I
WAS KIND OF BY MYSELF FOR ABOUT
A YEAR.
I AND SO I ACTUALLY AT THAT
POINT AND I HAD NO BUDGET.
BUT NOT FOUNDATIONS WHO I WILL
SAY IN.
TWO THOUSAND TEN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
MILLION TWO THOUSAND TEN I HAD.
TWO MILLION ACTUALLY ONE MILLION
AND TWO MILLION AND SO IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN THOSE FOUNDATIONS
THAT WE HAVE FUNDED IN -- TWO
THOUSAND WHO DID AMAZING WORK
THEY CAME FORTH AND DEDICATED
ABOUT NINE MILLION OF THEIR OWN
DOLLARS.
SO AS I CAME IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IT WAS FOUNDATIONS
WERE ALREADY TALKING ABOUT HOW
WE NEED TO START TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO.
FOR TWENTY OF PARTICULARLY --
AFTER FALL OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
THEY KNEW THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO HAVE TO START THIS
CONVERSATION EARLIER.
SO WE'VE BEEN HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS UP FRONT OTHERS A
COUPLE KEY FOUNDATIONS THAT HAVE
ALREADY INVESTED.
MILLIONS OF THEIR OWN THE
CALIFORNIAN DUMB IS ONE THAT
DEFINITELY COMES TO MIND AND
WE'VE BEEN PARTNERING OFTEN VERY
BEGINNING -- WE ALSO MEET WITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GRANT MAKERS
GRANT MAKERS CONCERNED WITH
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AT GRANT MAKERS AND
THEN OUR ADMINISTRATIVE.
OUT TO ME BASS ORGANIZATIONS
THOSE ARE MAINLY FOUNDATIONS
THAT HAVE -- THAT ADMINISTRATIVE
REACH AN UNDERSTANDING OF THOSE
REGIONS IN ORDER.
TO TAKE THE STATE REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE WE DO HAVEREQUIREMENTS
ON OUR DOLLARS AND BE ABLE TO
PUSH THOSE OUT.
NOW THERE ARE THOSE WHO ALREADY
INVESTED I MENTIONED A FEW OF
THEM AND THERE'S BEEN A BIG
GROUP HAVE BEEN MEETING IN A
FUNDER CIRCLE BOTH NATIONALLY
AND LOCALLY. TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE NEED TO DO AND AND FRANKLY
SOME OF THEM IN LIKE WOW THE
STATE YOU KNOW THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY -- WE'VE TOLD THEM DON'T
PULL BACK JUST LET'S GET WE'RE
GONNA LAY OUR FOUNDATION BUT
THERE'S GOING TO BE THINGS.
THAT WE CAN'T FUND FRANKLY WITH
STATE TAX DOLLARS AND THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO PROBABLY
LEAN ON OUR PARTNERS TO SAY THIS
IS WHERE WE NEED TO HELP YOU TO
HELP US.
FILL THOSE GAPS SO WE'RE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM AS WE
HEAD INTO THE SUMMER WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING OUR IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN WORKSHOPS.
WHERE BOTH THIS FOUNDATIONS ALL
ARE FUNDED PARTNERS AND THOSE ON
THE GROUND WILL COME TOGETHER TO
SAY WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DEPLOY
COME JANUARY?
SO WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING THIS
FALL OF WHAT THOSE GAPS ARE AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A PLAN TO
FILL THOSE.
AND FINALLY -- I BELIEVE THAT.
WORKING THROUGH OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE --
THAT'S A GREAT ADVANTAGE AND A
GREAT RESOURCE FOR GETTING OUT
ESPECIALLY TO HARD TO COUNT.
I MEAN THERE IS IT THERE'S
PROBABLY THERE'S VERY FEW PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS.
THAT HAVE THE TRUST.
OF OUR SISTERS AND BROTHERS IN
THE HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITIES --
SO -- AGAIN I CAN'T THINK OF YOU
KNOW TEACHER COULD WALK UP AND
KNOCK ON THE DOOR OF SOMEONE.
AND THERE'D BE NO PROBLEM NO
ISSUES OF TRUST-- YOU KNOW
OTHERS OR YOU KNOW HOW DIFFERENT
TITLES AND POSITIONS THAT WOULD
BE SO EASY TO DO.
OR THEY CAN JUST DO IT THROUGH
THEIR CHILDREN THROUGH THE
MEDIAN SO WHATEVER IT IS
WHATEVER LEGALLY THEY'RE ALLOWED
TO DO.
BUT I BELIEVE THEY NEED THE
RESOURCES BECAUSE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ALREADY EXISTS WE
DON'T HAVE TO HIRE MORE PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE TO DO ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS.
THEY ALREADY EXIST.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT AND BY I
KNOW IN.
THE BUDGET IT'S ACTUALLY A VERY
SMALL.
UP AMOUNT AND I DON'T KNOW THAT.
BY NOT INVESTING.
YOUNG IN THAT PARTICULAR SECTOR
WE MAY BE MISSING THE BOAT.
RIGHT -- SO THANK YOU FOR THAT I
DO BELIEVE THE YOUTH ARE THAT IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE DID GET
SOME FUNDING SO WHAT I NOTICED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND
TEN THE WORK OF THE US CENSUS
BUREAU WAS THEY HAD A SENSE OF
SOME SCHOOLS PRORAM.
AND THEY PARTNERED WITH
SCHOLASTIC.
SCHOLASTIC INC YOU KNOW
AND THEY SENT US LIKE PALLETS OF
THINGS TO HAND OUT BUT IT BUT
FRANKLY THERE REALLY PRETTY BUT
THERE WAS A DAY LATE AND A
DOLLAR SHORT WE COULDN'T
POSSIBLY GET IT OUT A WEEK
BEFORE.
SO TWO THOUSAND TEN SAME THING
SLOW TO IT SO IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHEN I CAME IN A SAID
WE NEED TO START WITH SCHOOLS
SO WE TOOK SOME DOLLARS WE
INVESTED -- WE CONTACTED --
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FRANK PZ RUNS THERE --
HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
CURRICULUM WE SAID HOW DO WE
WORK IT INTO THE CURRICULUM WE
DON'T PUT MORE ON TEACHERS IN
TERMS OF THAT BUT WE HAD A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY. TO ENGAGE FIFTH
EIGHTH ELEVENTH AND TWELFTH
GRADERS AT THE TIME I DOLLARS IN
EIGHTH GRADE AND SHE WITH.
WHAT CAME HOME FROM HER AND GET
HISTORY THING SHE'S A MOM WE
TALK ABOUT THE CENSUS TODAY?
AND ISN'T REALLY WHAT DID YOU
TALK ABOUT SHE SAID IT WAS A
GLOSSARY WORD.
AND THAT WAS IT.
AND I SAID WELL DID YOU SAY
ANYTHING AS HE SAID YEAH I DID
IT BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER.
AND SHE TOLD THEM WHY IT WAS SO
IMPORTANT THAT YOU HAD TO FILL
THIS OUT AND A PERSON TEACHERS
LIKE -- YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW VOIGTS IT JUST EVERY
YEAR AND THE KIDS SAID I'M NOT
THE OWNER OUT.
AND SHE SAID WATCH LIKE.
IT'S TOO MUCH INFORMATION THAT'S
LOOK LIKE MY PRIVACY IS ONLY ONE
AND SHE SAID TO THEM.
YOU KNOW YOU FOR A LOT MORE WHEN
YOU FILL OUT A WHAT YOU KNOW
HOUSE OF A WIZARDRY YOU KNOW
HUFFLEPUFF THAT YOU ARE WHEN YOU
FILL OUT A BUS.
FOR BECAUSE HE WANTED TO PUT IT
IN THE LIKE IT'S SAFE SO THE
ANYWAYS LONG STORY SO I SAID YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
TEACHERS IN FIFTH.
EIGHT ELEVEN TWELVE THAT'S A
TIME WHEN THEY'RE LEARNING ABOUT
THE CONSTITUTION THAT'S WHEN
THEY'RE LEARNING ABOUT OUR
STATE'S HISTORY THAT'S WHEN
THEY'RE LEARNING ABOUT AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT.
TWELFTH GRADERS STUDY AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT THAT'S WE'RE CREATING
OUR VOTERS RIGHT WE'RE CREATING
THAT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
SO THEY'VE PULLED ELEVENTH
TWELFTH FIFTH AND EIGHTH GRADERS
AT LA LAKERS ALWAYS IT IS ALSO
INVOLVED AND THE CREATED A
CURRICULUM -- AND PACING GUIDES
THAT WOULD TAKE A SAID FRANK
IT'S GONNA TAKE A TEACHER LESS
THAN TEN IS A GREAT WAY TO PUT
THAT IN.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T PUT MORE IN OUR
TEACHERS SO THERE TO POINT OUT
RIGHT NOW ACTIVELY BUT IN
ADDITION WE HAVE A WE'VE
PROPOSED OF FORTY DIFFERENT
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
DOLLARS AND WE WANT TO REQUIRE
THEM WHEN THEY GET THE DOLLARS
TO HAVE A SENSE THIS WEEK TO
OPEN UP THEIR PARENT RESOURCE
CENTERS ON THE COMPUTER CENTERS
IN THE MEDIA CENTERS WHERE
THERE'S ACTUALLY.
YOU KNOW ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
TO HAVE THOSE OPEN.
A SAFE PLACE FOR PARENTS TO COME
TO BE ABLE TO FILL OUT THE FORM
SO WE CAN STAFF OF WITH WITH THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS ARE
WE CAN ACTUALLY STEPPED IN WITH
THE YOUTH THAT ARE GONNA WELCOME
AND LEARN ABOUT THIS -- SO IT'S
IT'S A MASSIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S OUT THERE AND WE SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY TAP INTO IT -- WE'VE
DEDICATED ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION OF OUR OUR BUDGET -- TO
THAT AND WE'RE CURRENTLY -- IN
CONTRACT WE'RE DOING ALL THE
CONTRACTS WITH ALL THE WE DID
FORTY OF THEM WHICH WERE THE TOP
TITLE ONE ENTITLED THREE WHICH
IS SCHOOL LUNCH.
ARE AND LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT.
OUT TO TRY TO GET THOSE DOLLARS
OUT.
YOU CAN GET SOME OF THE MONEY
FROM THE PR AND PUT IT IN THERE.
OKAY -- SEVERAL BURKE ANYMORE.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE A AND A
LOOK FOR DISSING THE METRICS
NUMBER TWO IS WE'RE GONNA DO
LITTLE STICKERS THE I COUNTED
STICKERS.
YOU GOT A PEN.
ARE WE GONNA DO THE STICKERS
LIKE THE I VOTED STICKERS YES
CORD ARM OKAY YEAH.
HELLO CAM THAT THE BUDGET THANK
YOU.
OKAY I'M A TO OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME THAT THE
RECORD MONA.
AND I WORK FOR IN PRINT MEDIA
WHICH ALSO OWNS Là PIGNON AN
OPINION THAT IDEA.
AND WE ARE HERE I'M SORRY I JUST
I JUST WANT WE HAVE A A NUMBER
OF SPEAKERS WE JUST WANT TO
REMIND YOU TO KEEP IT. ONE TO
TWO MINUTES FOR A SHORT THAT'S
ALREADY GOING.
TO ABSOLUTELY THANK.
ANY BUT I JUST WANT TO WELCOME
AND THANK EVERYBODY THANK YOU
MADAM.
CHAIR AND I'M ALSO HERE COMPANY
BY A NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF A AND
F. THINK MEDIA COALITION THE
REPRESENTS.
NEARLY A HUNDRED OUTLETS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE -- WE'RE HERE
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S. THIRTY MILLION
RECOMMENDED AUGMENTATION AND
CONSIDER EXPANDING THAT BY SIX
MILLION.
WHILE GOVERNOR BROWN'S BUDGET
MADE HISTORY IN THE INVESTMENT
ON THE CENSUS IT REALLY LEFT.
MEDIA SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERFUNDED
IN ORDER TO HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
CAMPAIGN AS WE ALL KNOW IN A
STATE AS LARGE AS CALIFORNIA WE
NEED A ROBUST CAMPAIGN.
AND WE THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOMMENDATION MAKES SENSE.
I THINK MEDIA PRINT TV RADIO
DIGITAL WILL BE CENTRAL. TO
ACCOMPLISHING A COMPLETE COUNT
PARTICULARLY IN HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
SO WE ARE HERE TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND THE YOU
CONSIDER A SMALL AUGMENTATION TO
THE GOVERNOR'S. THIRTY MILLION
OUR RECOMMENDATION BY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JULIE
SNYDER REPRESENTING HOUSING
CALIFORNIA WE ARE HERE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE REQUEST BY
THE CENSUS POLICY ADVOCACY
NETWORK. FOR AN ADDITIONAL
NINETY THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
TO ALLOW CBO'S TO REACH THEIR
HARD TO KIND HELP CLIENTS AS
WELL AS OTHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
HOUSING CALIFORNIA JOINS SEE
POUND EARLY LAST YEAR TO PROVIDE
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE UNSTABLE
HOUSE OR ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS -- SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT FACE AN ACCURATE
COUNT OF CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDE THEIR LACK OF A FIXED
ADDRESS THEIR SEVERE LACK OF
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET.
AS WELL AS A WARINESS OF
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS OF BEST
PRACTICES FOR REACHING THAT
WOULD INCLUDE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HIRING AND NUMERATORS
WHO HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE.
AND CAN CUT THROUGH THIS
MISTRUST OF GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
WE ARE NOT CONFIDENT HOWEVER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL TAKE
THAT STEP -- ONE MORE THING IS
THAT AN ACCURATE COUNT
DETERMINES OUR STATE'S ALLOTMENT
OF HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHERS AS
WELL AS NUMEROUS OTHER HOUSING
RESOURCES -- THAT ARE VERY
VALUABLE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING ON MODEST BUDGET -- SO
REALLY THE STATE INVESTMENT IN
CBO OUT REACHES FROM OUR%
PERSPECTIVE A CLEAR STRATEGY FOR
HELPING TO ADDRESS OUR MOUTHS OF
HOUSING CRISIS.
SO WE WANNA THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING SEE POUNDS REQUIRE
US TO INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE ITS
FAIR SHARE OF THESE RESOURCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ATTENTION MEMBERS MIGHT THE
GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE STARTED OUR
EFFORT ON ADDRESSING OUR SENSES --
TWENTY TWENTY OUT REACH AND OVER
TWO YEARS AGO I'M SHARING WITH
YOU SOME OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED TO ADDRESS -- HOW
TO DO AGGRESSIVE OUTREACH I MEAN
GOING OUT THERE GOING OUT TO THE
COUNTY -- YOU KNOW LIBRARIES
HEALTH CLINICS USING OUR ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS EMPLOYEES
SO THEY MAKE WE CAN TRACK THOSE
THAT.
NEED TO BE COUNTED AND WE ALSO
HAVE GONE TO HOUSE TO HOUSE TO
SEE WHO YOU KNOW WHERE PEOPLE
ARE NOT THIS INTERNET ADDRESS SO
THAT WE CAN DO SOME MORE OUT
REACH -- THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR
US WHICH IS WHY WE WERE ASKING
FOR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WE ASK
FOR TWELVE MILLION -- IN THE
LAST BUDGET CYCLE BUT WE WE
DIDN'T RECEIVE THE EXACT AMOUNT --
SO SINCE THEN WE REALIZED AS A
RESULT OF ADDITIONAL WORK WITH
THE STATE WE ARE SHORT AN
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION BECAUSE OF NEW
REQUIREMENTS -- NEW LANGUAGE TO
MEET NEW LANGUAGE REQUIREMENTS
AND TO ALSO PROVIDE -- OUT
REGION SOME OF THE AREAS THAT
I'VE JUST DESCRIBED SO WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAY.
THANK YOU MADAME CHIANG
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YET THEY'RE BANISH A SIN TO BE
GAINED SHARE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
BEGAY AND I'M A CITIZEN OF THE
NAVAJO NATION HOPI.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTE PROJECT TO JESS
TRIBAL ART WHICH FUNDING FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE SLIPPED THROUGH THE CRACKS
IN ERASURE IMPAIR OF AN AFFAIR
ACCOUNT OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE'S.
OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR POINT ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
DEDICATED DISENTIS AT RISK
BUDGET.
ONLY POINT 2% OF THE BUDGET AT
THE A LITTLE OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED TO TRIBES.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO THE SECOND
HIGHEST NUMBER A FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN THE US A
HUNDRED AND TEN TO BE EXACT.
COMPARED TO THE REST OF THE
NATION CALIFORNIA HAS THE
LARGEST POPULATION OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
WERE DONE IF I AS AMERICAN
INDIAN AND ALASKA NATIVE ALONE
OR IN COMBINATION WITH ANOTHER
RACE.
OF THESE ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA FORTY TWO
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR SENSES THAT
REACH MINDING BASED ON THE
HOUSING UNIT FORMULA.
AND OF THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
MOST WILL ONLY RECEIVE AT
THOUSAND OR TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
TO REACH THEIR CITIZENS.
DUE TO LOW BUDGET RIGHT NOW ONLY
TWELVE CAT TOOK TWELVE TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE OPTED IN AS OF
MARCH EIGHTEENTH.
NATIVE AMERICANS HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN THE MOST HARD
TO COUNT POPULATION AND IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN NATIVE AMERICANS
SPECIFICALLY THOSE LIVING A
TRIBAL LANDS.
EXPERIENCE IN AN F. 5% UNDER
COUNT WHICH IS TWICE AS HIGH AS
A NEXT HARD TO COUNT POPULATION.
AN ACCURATE COUNT MEANS DOLLARS
FOR CENSUS -- THEIR DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS LIKE TENNIS CHIP WAY.
THERE'S STILL TIME TO CORRECT
THIS WE BUILD OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY STATE COMMITTEES
LICENSES AS WELL SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEES TO
CORRECT THIS DRASTIC
UNDERFUNDING AN INCREASE FUNDING
TO EACH TRIBE BY 4100%.
WE ASK THAT THE MINIMUM AMOUNT
PROVIDED TO EACH TRIBE IS FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS REGARDLESS OF
TRIBAL POPULATION SIZE WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO NOT COUNT CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLES AND WE CAN'T BE
COMPLICIT IN THE ERASURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
AND I'M SURE.
WE'RE WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THAT --
I'M SURE YOU STARTED TO BUT IT
IS A MATTER OF MORE RESOURCES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I JUST WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY
WE GIVING TWO MINUTES -- MAX
THANK YOU VERY AWAY I'LL BE
QUICKER THAN THAT HOW ABOUT THAT.
MY NAME IS REALLY DOESN'T MEAN
THE NEXT WEEK GETS MORE TIME.
WHAT WE'RE PART OF A COALITION
MY NAME IS REGINA BROWN WILSON
AND I AM THAT CHAIR WELL THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ACTUALLY
RIGHT NOW?
OF CALIFORNIA BLACK MEDIA ON ONE
OF WE JUST WANTED BASICALLY
KNOWLEDGE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S --
PROPOSED -- ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND THE FUNDING THAT THE CENSUS
OFFICE RECOGNIZE - TO PUT INTO
ON ETHNIC MEDIA WE YOU KNOW
COMPLETELY SUPPORT THAT -- WE
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF ETHNIC
MEDIA -- WHEN YOU START TALKING
ABOUT CRISIS COMMUNICATIONS THAT
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT THE NEGATIVE
INFORMATION THAT MAY COME OUT --
THAT'S OUR MEDIA OUTLETS WHAT
THEY DO IS THEY ARE ABLE TO VET
INFORMATION MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET PROPER INFORMATION OUT TO
THE COMMUNITY.
AND SO WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS ALSO HED IN REGARD
IS HOW WE LOOK AT THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THEY COME
AND THEY LEAN ON THE SAME.
MEDIA OUTLETS TO HELP DISTRIBUTE
AND PUSH OUT INFORMATION SO WE
WANT TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW THIS
IS A VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND WE
HOPE THAT YOU GUYS WILL CONTINUE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PATRICIA BUCHANAN
AND I REPRESENT THE TELEMUNDO
STATION GROUP -- SO THE TIMER TO
STATIONS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE KNOW THAT THE
LATINO POPULATION IS IN A PART
OF IT OF THE ETHNIC MEDIA COUNT
COALITION AS WELL.
AND AND I'M HERE TO BASICALLY
SAY THAT -- WE NEED TO EDUCATE
AND ENGAGE -- THE HISPANIC
COMMUNITY AND THIS IS A CRITICAL
TIME AND WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF FEAR IN THE COMMUNITY AND
EXACTLY TO THAT POINT -- WE HAVE
A A NEWS ORGANIZATION AND NEWS
SOURCES THAT ARE VERY TRUSTED IN
THE COMMUNITY AND AND THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY DEFINITELY
NEEDS TO KNOW AND UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE SENSES.
AND ALSO NEEDS TO KNOW --
EXACTLY WHAT CRITICAL RESOURCES
THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY -- THAT
ARE AFFECTING THEIR LIVES
SIMILAR TO THE THE FIRST -- FIVE
AND ALSO SOME OF THE HEALTHCARE
RESOURCES THAT THEY'RE USING AND
THE FUNDING IF WE DON'T GET THEM
COUNTED THEN THEY WON'T HAVE THE
FUNDING IN THE FUTURE.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
DRIVEN HOME AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
A WE SUPPORT -- ALL OF THE
EFFORTS ON THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SIDE BUT WE DO
NEED THAT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR THE
MEDIA SERVICES PLUS THE
ADDITIONAL -- SIX MILLION THAT
WE'VE ASKED FOR AND IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THOSE GOALS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LIKE.
IS IF WE DON'T HAVE -- ON THE
GROUND AS WELL AS REINFORCEMENT
FROM PARTICULARLY FROM OUR
ETHNIC MEDIA -- IT JUST DOESN'T
WORK AS WELL SO THE COMBINATION
OF THE TWO IS REALLY REALLY
POWERFUL AND ETHNIC MEDIA ALSO
IN MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN HAVE
BEEN. FOR THE COMMUNITIES NOT
TRYING TO BE QUOTE UNQUOTE
NEUTRAL.
ADVOCATE FOR A COMMUNITY THAT
PUTS YOU IN A HIGHER PLACE OF
TRUST.
AND RESPECT SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RUN AT THE LIMóN FOR ALL
THAT YOU DO.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KELLY GROWTH
THAT'S NEXT IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE SENSES POLICY
ADVOCACY NETWORK REQUEST FOR AN
ADDITIONAL NINETY THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION TO ENSURE A
COMPLETE COUNT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SERGEANT
SAYING I AM A PART OF THE CBO
CHICANO MOVEMENT -- AND I'M
ACTUALLY A MEMBER OF SENATOR
NIELSEN'S DISTRICT.
JEFF TODD IN OCOEE GOT ABOUT GOT
A I HAVE.
A TON OR NOT THE BOSS ON THE
SOME JOB IF IT OPEN UP NEW
COFFEE BUT I LIKE THAT.
IF SOMEONE IS SPEAKING TO YOU
AND YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
LANGUAGE THAT THEY'RE USING THEN
IT DOESN'T FEEL VERY GOOD.
THIS IS HOW MANY OF MY PIN JABI
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FEEL WHEN THEY
ARE ENGAGING WITH GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES OR TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND ANY SORT OF
DOCUMENTATIONS.
BUT JABI IS THE TENTH MOST
SPOKEN LANGUAGE IN CALIFORNIA
AND AT THE SAME TIME NEARLY 40%
OF OUR COMMUNITY HAS LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY.
THEREFORE WE ARE LACKING THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED IN ORDER
TO CONDUCT OUR DAILY LIVES NOW
THE CENSUS IS A WAY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY TO GET MORE RESOURCES.
HOWEVER IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
THEY HAVE TO NAVIGATE THE SENSES
IN A LANGUAGE THAT HOW MANY
MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
AND SO IT'S WHAT WE ARE
ADVOCATING FOR IS MORE LANGUAGE
RESOURCES IN PUNJAB B. AND OTHER
UNDER REPRESENTED LANGUAGES AND
SO WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE IS.
ONE TRUSTED MESSAGING -- SO EASY
TO UNDERSTAND MESSAGING THAT'S
GIVEN BY TRUSTED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY -- SPECIFICALLY ETHNIC
MEDIA FOR INSTANCE RADIO AND
NEWSPAPER SECOND WOULD BE MORE
WRITTEN LANGUAGE RESOURCES THAT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS CAN TURN TO IF
THEY WANT TO LEARN ABOUT OR
UNDERSTAND THE SENSE IS BETTER.
THIRD WOULD BE DIRECTLY WORKING
AND PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITY
GROUPS WHO CAN PROVIDE THESE
TRANSLATIONS WHO CAN HELP
WITHOUT REACH EFFORTS AND WHO
CAN WORK DIRECTLY WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
AND EVENTUALLY DOWN THE LINE WE
WOULD NEED TO HIRE AN NUMERATORS
WHO ARE BY LEGALLY PROFICIENT
AND BEEN JABI AND IN ENGLISH I
HOPE THAT WE CAN.
BE INVEST IN ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS AND BY DOING SO WE REACH
OUR HIGH TO COUNT COMMUNITIES
AND ENSURE AN EQUITABLE SENSES
TWENTY TWENTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- JUST IN TIME.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR SENATOR
UMBERG MY NAME IS JENNIFER
FEARING ON THE SACRAMENTO
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFITS WE ARE
AT TEN THOUSAND MEMBER
ORGANIZATION POLICY ALLIANCE.
HEARING CALIFORNIA AND ACCORDING
TO OUR RECENT CAUSES COUNT
REPORT NONPROFITS ARE THE MOST
TRUSTED OF INSTITUTIONS AS
COMPARED TO GOVERNMENT OR OR THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND AT LAST COUNT.
MORE THAN A MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ARE EMPLOYED -- UP BY NONPROFITS
IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S NOT
COUNTING ALL OF THE MANY
VOLUNTEERS THAT ARE PARTICIPATE
AB ROBUSTLY SO THAT'S A LOT OF
TRUSTED MESSENGERS -- THAT WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DEPLOY --
IN THE EFFORT TO COUNT
CALIFORNIA'S IN THE CENSUS SO
ADD TO THAT AND COMMON PROFITS
IS AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN THE
C. PAN NETWORK AND WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO AUGMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ALIGNED WITH THE C. PEN
REQUEST THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI THEIR CRAFT ALMOST AFTERNOON --
CHAIR AND UNDER I'M VERY -- I'M
HERE PART OF THE MEDIA COALITION
FOR ETHNIC -- SPECIFIC OUTRAGE A
LOT OF THE TIMES -- BY THE WAY
MY NAME'S ANY ADDRESSES WITH
UNIVISION -- A LOT OF THE TIMES
OF THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE NETWORKS
I HAVE AN INFLUX OF IN FROM OF
THE BUDGET AND FUNDING.
AND SOMETIMES IT'S IT'S WONDERED
BECAUSE YOU OVER SUCH A MARKET
AND SO -- ALLOCATING THOSE
DOLLARS AND FUNDING AND SUPPORT
TO ETHNIC MEDIA PAID.
MEDIA OUTREACH IS VERY CRUCIAL
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE TIMES I
THINK ME HAS BEEN SEEN AS EARNED
OR FREE -- BUT THAT IS NOT GOING
TO BE THE CASE IN ORDER TO HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL CENSUS IN TWENTY
TWENTY I'M PART OF A MIXED OUT
ITS HOME AND I AM.
THE EXAMPLE OF THE FEAR THAT IS.
INSTILLED IN OUR HOME AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE UP AGAINST
AND IDEAS -- MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT WE ARE SOMETIMES THAT THE
KIDS THIS THE CHILDREN'S ARE
THOUGH ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE FILLING OUT THE
CENSUS OR TRANSLATING THINGS
BECAUSE THIS IS HOW WE'VE.
GROWN IN OUR COMMUNITIES BUT IN
ADDITION TO HIGHLIGHTING THE
POWER HOUSE OF MEDIA TELLING
WHEN THE WHEN YOU SEE ON OUR
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
I'M MEDIA AT THE NATIVE AMERICAN --
PRINT MEDIA AS WELL WE ARE HERE --
TO WORK WITH EACH OTHER AND ALSO
SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND S. MATCHING THE GROUND GAME
WITH THE AIR GAME AS WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CENTER CERAM SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND WE ARE
COMMUNITY BASED CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION LOCATED IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S CHINATOWN.
SINCE OUR FOUNDING IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE WE'VE WORKED ON EVERY
DECENNIAL CENSUS FOR THE PAST
FIVE DECADES AND A COMMITMENT
REMAINS CONSTANT WHICH IS TO
HELP ENSURE A FAIR AND ACCURATE
COUNT. FOR A LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT POPULATIONSLAST YEAR
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES.
THEY ESTABLISH THE NEED FOR
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR CENSUS
TWENTY TWENTY AND ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT THAT
PLAN.
MUST DO IS TO SPECIFY HOW THE
LANGUAGE GAPS WILL BE ADDRESSED
WITH STATE AND LOCAL EFFORTS
THIS IS CRUCIAL BECAUSE THE US
FEDERAL CENSUS BUREAU.
DOES NOT INCLUDE -- HAS EXCLUDED
KEY LANGUAGES FROM THE PAPER
SURVEY AND THE ONLINE DIGITAL
SURVEY SO ARE LACKEY LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN BECOMES EVEN MORE
CRITICAL IN REACHING ARE HARD TO
COUNT POPULATIONS.
SO WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW IT.
WE THINK IT IS LACKING IN
DETAILS REGARDING OUR LOW ELLIE
P. POPULATION.
US ALONG WITH OTHER CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
SUBMITTED WRITTEN
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE STATE
CENSUS OFFICE AND WE HOPE TO SEE
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDED
IN THE NEXT ITERATION OF THE
PLAN WE ALSO ASK THE STEPPED.
PAYMENT FOR COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK WE SHOULD.
HI GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING -- SENSES
ARE EACH FUNDING TO THE FLOOR
TODAY MY NAME IS A SPENT ON TO
GIVE OUT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CHIRLA STATEWIDE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION.
AS WELL AS A TRUSTED MESSENGER
WITH NATIONAL IMPACT FOUNDED IN --
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX TO ADVANCE
AND PROTECT THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES.
WE APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEES
COMMITMENT TO ACHIEVING AN
ACCURATE CENSUS COUNT AS WELL AS
THAT OF THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
CAL COMMITTEE -- AND THEIR STAFF
FOR THEIR SUPPORT.
OUR PARTNERS IN THE CENSUS
POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK SEE PAN
HAVE BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY TO
ELEVATE THE IMPORTANCE OF FULL
FUNDING FOR OUTREACH EFFORTS AND
WE THANK THEM FOR SUBMITTING OUR
FUNDING REQUEST LETTER FOR
TODAY'S HEARING.
CHIRLA IS PROUD TO BE WORKING
WITH THE STATE TO REACH HARD TO
COUNT COMMUNITIES IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS INCLUDING
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES AND AND
ELLIE P. INDIVIDUALS.
HOWEVER THIS DOES IN A PHOBIA
AND FEAR THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS AMPLIFIED MAKES REACHING OUR
COMMUNITIES WHICH WERE ALREADY
HARD TO THE HARDEST ACCOUNT IN
THE NATION.
MORE DIFFICULT THAN EVER OF THE
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN ALLOCATED
FOR CENSUS OUT REACH STILL FALL
SHORT.
ESPECIALLY DIRECT FUNDING FOR
CBO'S LIKE OURS AND OUR PARTNERS
WHO ARE TRUSTED MESSENGERS.
AS WE WAIT TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THE CITIZENSHIP QUESTION WILL BE
INCLUDED IN THE CENSUS ANXIETY
AND FEAR CONTINUES TO FESTER IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANKFULLY BEING A TRUSTED
MESSENGER MEANS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO CUT THROUGH SOME
OF THAT FEAR.
IT MEANS THAT BECAUSE OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE KNOWN US AND
OUR WORK FOR DECADES.
THEY CAN TRUST US IT MEANS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO TELL OUR
MOTHERS OUR BROTHERS OUR FAMILY
BY THE CENSUS IS SO IMPORTANT.
AND AS I WAS TELLING MY OWN MOM
ABOUT MY WORK ON THE CENSUS
WHICH CHIRLA.
SHE AN IMMIGRANT FROM MEXICO WAS
PREVIOUSLY UNDOCUMENTED ADMITTED
TO ME THAT SHE HAD TO FILL OUT
THE CENSUS IN.
TWENTY TEN MY PARENTS WHO HAVE
NOW BEEN IN THIS COUNTRY FOR
OVER THREE DECADES HAD ONLY
RECEIVE THIS FORM ONCE OR MAYBE
TWICE AND SHE HAD NO IDEA WHAT
IT WAS.
AND WHY THE GOVERNMENT WAS
ASKING.
WHY THE GOVERNMENT WAS ASKING
HER TO PROVIDE THE CENSUS
INFORMATION TO BE HONEST SHE
DIDN'T TRUST THE GOVERNMENT
ENOUGH TO FILL OUT THIS FORM?
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND SENATOR.
THANK YOU FOR A ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK HERE THIS AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS WANT TO SPONSOR LARA
I'M THE EDITOR OF OF VETO AND
INVITE YOU.
A BILINGUAL NEWSPAPER THAT --
WILL TURN THIRTY YEARS OLD NEXT.
NEXT YEAR AND IS THE COUNTRY'S
LARGEST BILINGUAL NEWSPAPER.
I HAVE TAKEN THIS WILL BE MY THE
SEVEN SINCE IS THAT I WILL BE
TAKING PART IN.
I'M NOT THAT OLD I WAS THREE
YEARS OLD WHEN THE FIRST ONE
CAME UP -- IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY BUT I WANT TO SAY
THAT THIS WILL BE THE MOST
CHALLENGING SENSORS -- TO DATE
AND I AGREE WITHOUT OUR PARTNERS
IN THE ETHNIC MEDIA COALITION
FOR THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO REACH.
THE COMMUNITY A COMMUNITY THAT
RELIES ON ETHNIC MEDIA BECAUSE
WE KNOW THEM WE UNDERSTAND WE
UNDERSTAND THEIR CULTURE THE
HONORS WE UNDERSTAND THEIR
LANGUAGE.
AND THE TRUST IS SO ARE YOU CAN
BE HERE TO SUPPORT THE ETHNIC --
MEDIA COALITION THANK THANK YOU.
I AM GRAHAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF THE PANS I REQUEST
FOR IT.
CBS TO DO AVERAGE TO
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE COMMUNITIES.
I WANT TO STRONGLY ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION ON THE NEED
FOR A ROBUST LANGUAGE ACCESS
PLAN.
THAT IS DETAILED HAS MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES THAT.
OUTLINES HOW IT'S GOING TO GAPS
LEFT BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND ALSO REFLECTS THE I ON RIGHT
AND AND SMALLER LANGUAGES AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT IT IS OVERSIGHT
AND COMMITMENT THAT THE LANGUAGE
ACT.
ISSUE THANK YOU ARE INTO THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR US
SENATOR ON BURKE MY NAME IS
FRANCIS IS SPIRITUAL FILIPINOS.
WERE BASED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE STARTED NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE WE'LL BE CELEBRATING
OUR SIXTY YEARS.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT.
AND ALSO THE CORE COLLABORATION
I GUESS THIS IS HISTORY FOR ALL
ETHNIC MEDIA HERE AS YOU CAN SEE.
ONE ONE IMPORTANT THING MAKE
THIS STATE GREAT BECAUSE WE MAKE
SURE.
ACCOUNT EVERYBODY AND NO ONE IS
LEFT BEHIND.
AND I'M HERE TO YOU KNOW TO
SUPPORT -- THIS IS THIS ON THE I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ALAN I
AM HERE WITH ETHNIC.
SENATE CLOSE AND I AM -- GOING
TO BE HELPING OUT WITH THE
KOREAN POPULATION TWO THOUSAND
TEN CENSUS SOWS THAT.
KOREAN POPULATION CALIFORNIA IS
9% AMONGST ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS WHICH I BELIEVE IS
GROSSLY UNDERCOUNTED.
AND I'D UP BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT CAREER BEDIA IT
JUST HAS ALMOST NO RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT FROM.
ANYBODY FROM THE STATE SO I AM
HERE T ADVOCATE -- CREE MEDIA
SERVICES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS LISA CHAIR
REPRESENTING ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE SEA PAN
BUDGET REQUEST FOR NINETY THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION. TO GO TO CVS
FOR OUT REACH THE CENSUS HAS
PROFOUND IMPLICATIONS NOT ON NOT
JUST ON FEDERAL FUNDING BUT
REDISTRICTING POLITICAL
REPRESENTATION AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT IN OUR STATE.
THAT IS WHY FUNDING IS NOT THE
ONLY NEED WE ALSO NEED A
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN THAT IS
ROBUST SPECIFIC AND INCLUSIVE.
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA'S A CO SIGNER
ON THE LETTER OF RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR THE CURRENT CENSUS LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN ALONG WITH CHINESE
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
AS MENTIONED THE FEDERAL CENSUS
BUREAU EXCLUDES VERY RELEVANT
LANGUAGES IN OUR STATE.
DIGITAL SURVEYS WILL NOT BE
PROVIDED IN LONG JABI MY TIE
MARSHALLESE TONGAN -- AMONG
OTHERS NOT ONLY -- IMPORTANT
IMMIGRANT VOICES BUT IMPORTANT
MINORITY VOICES.
FAILURE TO CONFRONT AND ADDRESS
THE OPERATIONAL AND ON THE
GROUND CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH PROVIDING.
ACCESS WILL JEOPARDIZE THAT THE
KIDS SEE OF ALL STATE DOLLARS IN
THE CENSUS EFFORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY -- TWO THINGS WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR
BUDGET REQUEST AND SECONDARILY.
LIKE LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE'VE
MADE A REQUEST FOR WAR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS BUT THAT WOULD
BE FOUR SEVEN BAY AREA COUNTIES
IN THE REGION.
THREE I'D BE ALLOCATED ON THE
BASIS.
AND IN THE CASE OF SANTA CLARA
THAT MONEY WOULD SUPPLEMENT.
LOCAL EFFORTS WHICH INCLUDED.
COUNTY BOARDS SUPERVISING.
CURRENT YEAR PROVIDING BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THEIR GENERAL.
BOB AND ARE LIKELY TO LOSE MORE
AND THE NEXT.
WE APPRECIATE TO WRITE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM TURN MEMBER --
FOR THE CHALLENGE OF IT BUT THE
**** PROJECT CALIFORNIA BUT HERE
REPRESENTING SENSE.
WORK.
OF OUR COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
AMONG MULTIPLE ORGANIZATIONS
STATE BUT ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP SHAPE
POLICY CONCERNING SENSES.
TWENTY TWENTY I'M I WANT -- TO I
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
ACKNOWLEDGING IN THE AGENDA -- I
REQUEST DEPENDS REQUEST FOR AN
ADDITIONAL NINETY THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS --
I BRIEFLY WHAT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT -- WHY THAT IS
IMPORTANT WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WE BELIEVE IT'S
NOT ENOUGH OR A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO THEIR JOB?
ARE THERE ARE NOW SINCE SHOWS
THAT THE COST OF THE BUREAUS
ACROSS THE STATE TO EDUCATE
ENCOURAGED MILLIONS OF HARD TO
COUNT CALIFORNIANS TO
PARTICIPATE IN TWENTY TWENTY
SENTENCES ABOUT HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
WE HAVE -- THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED SOME FUNDING LAST YEAR
WE BELIEVE ANOTHER NINETY THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IS
NEEDED -- FOR THOSE EFFORT.
OUT WHAT ARE YOU KNOW YOU ASKED
WATER WHO ARE HARD TO COUNT --
POPULATIONS WE ABOUT SIXTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ACCORDING TO OUR ANALYSIS.
THAT FALL UNDER POPULATIONS THAT
FALL UNDER HARD TO COUNT TRACKED
AND POPULATIONS ABOUT LIKE
ELEVEN MILLION ABOUT ELEVEN
MILLION IN HARD TO CONTRACT AND
THEN ABOUT FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION.
THAT ARE CONSIDERED POPULATION
FOR VARIOUS REASONS -- AS YOU
JUST MENTIONED.
OF WE BELIEVE CBO IS OUR BEST
POSITION TO DO A PROPER OUT
REACH BY WAY OF TRUSTED
MESSENGERS AS MANY OF YOU HAVE
HEARD FROM MANY OF FOR A MY
COLLEAGUES -- INDIVIDUALS WHO
CAN JUST MESSENGERS INDIVIDUALS
WHO CAN VALIDATE GOVERNMENT
MESSAGES AND ALLEVIATE ANXIETY
ABOUT -- RESPONDING TO
QUESTIONNAIRES OR NUMERATOR --
FOR INSTANCE IF IMMIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA WEATHER DOCUMENTED
UNDOCUMENTED OR OF MIXED STATUS
FAMILIES REFUSED TO SELL RESPOND
TO BE OFFENSIVE QUESTION YEAR
OUT OF FEAR ABOUT HOUSE THAT IS
A CITIZEN -- SHIP DATA MIGHT BE
USED IN THE STATE'S POPULATION
COUNT WILL BE HIGHLY INACCURATE.
TRUST MESSAGES WILL BE KEY TO
WRITING THIS OUTCOME WE HAVE --
PROVIDED A VERY SHORT SIX PAGE
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE OF WITH
A LOT OF DETAILS.
ALSO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
COMMITTEE -- AND I DID MISS
RATIONS TO GET THAT OR THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI.
TINA WITH CHILDREN NOW.
BUT THE CANARIES THAT'S NO
CHILDREN NOW -- WANTED TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AS AN ECHO COULD
YOU JUST COMMENT AROUND AND ONE
OF THE MAIN THINGS AND CHILDREN
NOW -- FOCUS ON CHILDREN'S
ISSUES PRENATAL -- TWENTY SIX AT
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT TWO POINT
TWO MILLION CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF FIVE OR UNDER COUNTED.
IN THE LAST CENSUS -- AND
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO NINE
MILLION CHILDREN OVER THREE
MILLION BETWEEN.
ZERO FIVE I'M HAVING.
A CHILD BETWEEN ZERO FIVE IN
YOUR HOME IS ADDS ADDITIONAL
STRESS YOUR HOME -- SO WE KNOW
THAT FAMILIES LIVING UNDER.
STRESS UNDER ADDITIONAL -- TO
REST WHETHER IT'S LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY HOMELESSNESS.
WE NEED THAT ADDITIONAL
MESSAGING AROUND HARD TO CATCH
CHILDREN BEING PART OF PART OUT
COMMUNITIES -- AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL
AND I'VE GIVEN ALL THESE
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES THAT THAT
WE MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO MARKETING OUT REACH
MEDIA.
CHILDREN ARE ARE HIGHLIGHTED AND
THAT THAT YOUR INFANT THE WHOLE
PERSON -- IS IS A KEY MESSAGE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M GLAD YOU
RAISED THAT ISSUE THANK YOU.
HELLO NO I BOTTOM --
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
AUGMENTATION IN HIS BUDGET WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
INVESTMENT FROM LAST YEAR AND
THE STAFF WORKING PORT.
OF MAKING A HARD ACCOUNT AND
HARD TO REACH AREAS [inaudible]
COUNTED.
WE STAND IN SUPPORT.
OF AN ADDITIONAL ASK THAT CENSUS
POLICY ADVOCATE NETWORK HAS DONE.
WE THINK IT'S VITAL FOR THAT WE
HAVE AN ACCURATE OUT.
WE ARE IN A SITUATION WHERE IT'S
TOO DANGEROUS. TO GO UNDER
FUNDED SO WE NEED TO ASK FOR
THIS ADDITIONAL MONEY.
WE ALSO STAND IN SUPPORT OF A
STRONG AND ROBUST LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
PLAN TO GUIDE AND HELP OUR
COMMUNITY SUPPORT THEM.
SERVING RURAL IMMIGRANT MIGRANT
FARMWORKER COMMUNITIES WE
ALREADY HAVE ACCESS ISSUES.
ISOLATION LANGUAGE BARRIERS.
AND WE HAVE.
A PROBLEM [inaudible]
THE POVERTY.
SO WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE CAN HELP
OUR FARMWORKERS COMMUNITIES BE
PART OF THE ANSWER AND NOT.
BE UP.
OUT THERE ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT
ANY SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRA MEMBERS.
I'M VERY RIVERA PRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WHERE STATE WIDE
IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS NONPROFIT THAT
WAS FOUNDED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS ON
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN WITH
COLOR WITH CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
SPECIFICALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A FOCUS ON MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES AND OVERSIGHT.
AS WELL AS AN INVESTMENT AND
SMALL -- LANGUAGE GROUPS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSE ANTONIO
CHOREOGRAPHER WITH UNIVISION AND
ON BEHALF OF THE THE COALITION.
I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS -- THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FAKE EWS
ABOUT THE MISINFORMATION OUT
THERE -- FORTUNATELY OR
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S OUR WE'LL
HEALTH WHAT WE DO FOR A LIVING
EVERY DAY THEY OUT PEOPLE RELY
ON US FOR THEIR INFORMATION ALL
OF THE COALITION.
I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S RIGHT WHERE
WE LIVE.
OUR COMMUNITY AFFAIRS DIRECTORS
ARE NEWS DIRECTORS.
OUR SALES PEOPLE WERE READY TO
HANDLE THE SITUATION AND WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE THIS.
WORK WERE READY FOR THE
CHALLENGE AND YOU MADE A GREAT
POINT ABOUT THE CBO'S WE WORK
WITH THOSE PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
WITH THERE'S A GREAT DAY WHETHER
THERE'S A CRISIS INFORMATION
GOOD NEWS GOES OUT BAD NEWS GOES
OUT PEOPLE LOOK TO US FOR THAT
INFORMATION.
IN AND WE'RE ON IT AND WE'RE
ALREADY TO SUPPORT IT WHAT WE
NEED FROM YOU ALL IS THAT
SUPPORT IN TERMS OF MONEY FOR
THAT ETHNIC GROUP.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
HELP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ROLE IN ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AFFAIRS -- HEARING NO.
NO MORE PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY.
I THINK.
SENATOR THAT IT.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH TO
EVERYONE -- AND FOR COMING OUT
AND TAKING THIS TIME
.
ISSUE SEVENTEEN THE NATIONAL
VOTER REGISTRATION ACT
MAINTENANCE AND EXPANSION.
BY THE WAY THERE WAS NO VOTE ON
ISSUE.
SIXTEEN IS IS HELD OPEN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I'M JANET LEAN AND SHE FOR
THE ELECTIONS DIVISION OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE.
ON THE SELLER HOME WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
SO WE'RE HERE TODAY TO REQUEST
ASSN ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATIONS
THE SECRETARY OF STATE BUDGET --
FOR THREE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
IN TRANSLATION SERVICES --
EDUCATIONAL AND TRAINING
MATERIALS FOR DESIGNATE AGENCIES
THE NATIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
ACT REQUIRES EACH STATE TO
DESIGNATE AGENCIES.
THAT PROVIDE PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES THAT
PROVIDE PRIMARILY SERVICES WITH
THE SERBS TO PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIESTHE OPPORTUNITY TO
REGISTER TO VOTE.
AND TINA SECRETARY STATE
DESIGNATED FOR ADDITIONAL
AGENCIES WHICH COVERED OVER A
HUNDRED DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
ACROSS THE STATE WHICH BRING THE
TOTAL OF DESIGNATIONS UP TO
EIGHTEEN AGENCIES.
I'M WE WERE ASKED -- THROUGH A
LAWSUIT TO INCREASE OUR
EXPANSION OF THE NATIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION ACT AND THEREFORE
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE DID EXPAND
THOSE TWO FOR ADDITIONAL
AGENCIES.
A GIVEN WITH THIS ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD THE SECRETARY OF STATE --
DOING THOSE FOUR DESIGNATIONS IS
REQUESTING THESE ACTORS THREE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
TRANSLATIONS OF OUR EDUCATIONAL
AND TRAINING MATERIALS. FOR
THESE NEW ENTITIES AND WE'RE
OPENED WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
ONLY YOU.
NEXT ROAD OF THE LA A WE WE HAVE
REYES NO CONCERNS PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NOW -- OKAY.
I KNOW SOME OF A BIRD I JUST
STEPPED OUT FOR A SECOND -- ARE
THERE ANY -- THE COMMENTS.
CAN MAKE SOMETHING UP HERE
[inaudible]
OKAY -- WE CAN DO THE BILL
[inaudible] THREE OKAY --
SENATOR -- I NEED SENATOR
UMBERG'S VOTE. TO MOVE FORWARD
ON THIS SO.
CAN -- WE DISABLED HOLD.
WHILE HERE AND MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
HERE WE GO -- SENATOR UMBERG BUT
NO WE WERE -- ON THE VOTER
REGISTRATION ISSUES SEVENTEEN
YOU MIGHT SINCE YOU'RE ON THE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD ANY.
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
ON THIS.
BUT INCREASING RIGHT THE NUMBER
OF COUNTY OFFICES.
THAT ADMINISTERED -- HELP ON
VOTER REGISTRATION CRACKED.
QUESTION.
OKAY -- THE NUMBER WILL TAKE A
VOTE.
I HAVE A MOTION -- APPROVAL --
AND POSED IN THE BUDGET --
SENATOR DRAWS UP YES.
ENTER NIELSEN CENTER I'M BURKE
YES.
THAT WAS EASY THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ISSUE.
EIGHTEEN DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
SENATOR UMBERG -- THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US TODAY ON ISSUE
EIGHTEEN ON THE AGENDA INCLUDES
TWO OF DC'S PORT BUREAU BCP'S
THAT REQUEST STOPPING AND
RESOURCES. TO ADDRESS PERMANENT
WORKLOAD AND OPERATIONAL NEEDS.
SPECIFICALLY ONE B. C. P. IS A
CONSOLIDATED FOURTEEN PURE
WORKLOAD PCP THAT WERE CROSSED
THAT REQUEST TWENTY EIGHT POINT
ONE POSITIONS.
AND SPECIAL FUND RESOURCES FROM
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN BUREAUS THAT
ADDRESSES LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT WORKLOAD NEEDS
MAINLY BASED ON INCREASING
WORKLOAD VOLUMES.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL IS OUR
CONSOLIDATED LEGISLATIVE
WORKLOAD BCP THAT REQUEST TWENTY
TWO POSITIONS AND SPECIAL FOR
RESOURCES AS WELL.
FROM NINE OF OUR BOARD JIM
HEROES TO ADDRESS WORKLOAD
CREATED BY RECENTLY PASSED
LEGISLATION.
DCA RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR PROPOSALS AND
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE.
BECAUSE THESE PROPOSALS CONTAIN
INDIVIDUAL BOARD IMPERIAL
REQUEST.
I HAVE PROGRAM REPRESENTATIVES
HERE AS WELL IN ATTENDANCE TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THE NEW MEMBERS.
HELLO I'M SORRY LA -- HI CHRISTY
WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVEN'T RAISED ANY
CONCERN FOR THESE PROPOSALS
FINANCE [inaudible]
NOPE.
OKAY SENATOR UMBERG SO M..
IS THIS COMMENT WITH RESPECT TO
INCREASES DUE TO FISCAL
IMPLEMENTATION.
SPEAK TO THAT A BIT ACTUALLY
THAT OF FISCAL PIECES IN OUR
NEXT PROPOSAL THE ADMIN REQUEST
I'M GETTING TOO FAR AHEAD OF
THEMSELVES.
BUT JUST DID INDULGE ME FOR A
SECOND MAYBE IF YOU RESPOND TO
THAT NOW THAT I WANT TO ASK IT
NOT SURE YEAH OUR OUR NEXT
PROPOSAL IS REQUESTING RESOURCES
TO TO SUPPORT FOR SCALE.
YOU KNOW THAT WHAT WE ARE WE
SAYS IN OFFICE GIRLS WORKING
WE'RE PAYING OUR VENDORS WERE
DOCUMENTING DEPOSITS IN CASH
WERE THE EXPENDITURES ARE
SHOWING.
THE PROBLEM WE'RE HAVING IS WITH
THE BACK OFFICE RECONCILIATION
OF THE SYSTEMS.
AS WELL AS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
FOURTEEN BUREAUS THAT REQUIRE
OUTPACED.
REPORTING OUT OUT OF THEIR BOARD
MEETINGS AND WE'RE HAVING
PROBLEMS GETTING.
IN A NICELY FORMATTED --
COMPLETELY FORMATTED DOCUMENTS
FOR THEM TO TO REPORT OUT THIS
INFORMATION SO GET A LOT OF THE
PROBLEMS WE'RE HAVING IS MORE SO
IN THE BACK OFFICE.
IN THE RECONCILIATION OF THE
SYSTEM.
OKAY.
BUT AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR
GETTING AHEAD OF OURSELVES
ASSEMBLY ARMS THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE ON THIS ON ISSUE.
BECAUSE I READ THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES WITH THE
SCALP SO.
YES WE'RE HAVING OUR ISSUE YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WORKING WITH
YOU KNOW DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
AND THE SCO AS WELL AS THE SCALE
IN IN TRYING TO RESOLVE SOME OF
OUR PROBLEMS BUT IT IS JUST
TAKING A LONGER THAN WE
ANTICIPATE.
I'LL LEAVE THAT FOR ANOTHER DAY
ARE YOU.
THEY WILL BE HERE.
OKAY -- PUBLIC COMMENT.
HEARING NONE.
ALL RIGHT OF COULD GET A STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE AS
BUDGET IT.
MOVE IT.
SENATOR BROTHER I SENATOR NELSON
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WITH THE NEXT ITEM.
OKAY I HAVE A QUESTION OF OKAY
SO.
I APOLOGIZE THAT IN INTERVIEWS
MYSELF I'M JENNISON TALKING ON
THE CHIEF FISCAL OFFICER THE
DEPARTMENT.
SO THE NEXT BC PEOPLE FOR YOU
YOU TODAY REQUEST BY POINT TWO
MILLION. TO TO FIND TWENTY FOUR
POINT FIVE POSITIONS FOR THE
FOLLOWING FIVE ADMINISTRATIVE AN
INVESTIGATIVE OFFICES AT DCA.
THE FIRST BEING THE BUSINESS
SERVICES A FISCAL OPERATIONS
REQUEST OF SEVEN POSITIONS AND
FINDING ON A TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM BASIS TO ADDRESS
SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD INCREASES.
AND HAS AUDIT REQUIREMENTS AN
EXCEEDINGLY COMPLEX ACCOUNTING
PROCESSES.
THESE RESOURCES WAS OR WILL
RESULT IN A MORE TIMELY
RECONCILIATION OF ACCOUNTING
RECORDS FASTER PROCESSING OF
INVOICES AND BETTER REPORTING OF
EXPENDITURES AND REVENUE
INFORMATION.
SECOND OF THE FIVE IS THE LEGAL
AFFAIRS DIVISION REQUEST THREE
YEAR LIMITED TERM FUNDING TO
SUPPORT SIX ATTORNEYS AND TO
SUPPORT STAFF. TO CREATE A
DEDICATED REGULATIONS UNIT TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY QUALITY AND
TIMELINESS OF REGULATION
PACKAGES AND TO INCREASE THE
OUTPUT TO MEET DEMAND.
THIS REGULATION UNIT INCLUDES
FUNDING TO ASSIST THE DEPARTMENT
TO IMPLEMENT A. B. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WILL REQUIRE
DCA PROGRAMS TO PROPAGATE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY REGULATION
PACKAGES BY JULY. ONE TWENTY
TWENTY A THIRD OFFICE IS THE
DIVISION OF INVESTIGATION WHICH
REQUEST OR TO HELP INVESTIGATE A
POSITIONS AND FINDING ALONG WITH
METAL CONSULTANT MONEY TOWARD
TRUST INVESTIGATOR CASE WORKLOAD
AN AGING CASES.
THIS WILL RESULT IN A MORE
EFFICIENT TIMELY AND HIGH
QUALITY INVESTIGATIVE WORK.
AS WELL THIS COSTS ARE DIRECTLY
FUNDED BY THE BOARDS IN HEROES
THAT SUPPORT THAT USE THE
SERVICES.
THE FOURTH OFFICE BEING THE
OFFICE OF HUMAN RESOURCES THAT
REQUEST FUNDING TO CONVERT THREE
OF THEIR PERMANENT INTERMITTENT
POSITIONS IN A PERMANENT FULL
TIME. TO HAVE TO ADDRESS
RECRUITMENT AND RICK RETURN TO
WORK WORKLOAD.
THIS WILL REMAIN WHAT THIS WILL
MAINTAIN THE CURRENT SERVICE
LEVELS WITHIN -- HR OUR OFFICE
OF HUMAN RESOURCES.
AND THE LAST OFFICE AT THE
OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
EXAMINATION SERVICES THAT WOULD
REQUEST TO POSITIONS IN FINDING.
TO MEET THE INCREASED WORKLOAD
DEMAND FOR DEVELOPING
MAINTAINING AND VALIDATED
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING
EXAMINATIONS.
AGAIN WE RESPECT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR PROPOSALS IN HERE
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
SO AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
COMPONENTS OF THIS -- PROPOSAL
OF SUMMER FUNDED BASED ON A
USAGE BASIS SO ESSENTIALLY IT'S
LIKE AN HOURLY BASIS FOR EXAMPLE --
SAYS THOSE INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE
THE INVESTIGATIONS AND
EXAMINATIONS FUNCTIONS -- SUMMER
FUNDED ON WHAT'S CALLED A RAT I
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY A CHARGE
THAT ON PASSED ON TO THE BOARDS
AND BUREAUS BASED ON THEIR
AUTHORIZED POSITION COUNT.
SO WE'RE RECOMMENDING REJECTING
THE COMPONENT THAT ARE PROPOSED
TO BE FUNDED OUT OF PRO RATA
UNDER A COUPLE REASONS FOR THAT
THE FIRST IS THAT WE THINK IT'S
PREMATURE GIVEN THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT I TO DO
AN EVALUATION OF AND IT
BASICALLY A BUSINESS PROCESS
REVIEW OF THEIR PRO RATA FUNDED
SERVICES.
I'M TO SEE IF THEY COULD
IDENTIFY ANY EFFICIENCIES AND
THIS WAS REALLY RELATED TO SOME
LONGSTANDING CONCERNS ABOUT --
DEFENDING ATTORNEYS PERRETTA
SERVICES.
I'M ONLY ONE OF A WHOLE SERIES
OF REVIEWS SO THAT'S PRESS
RELATIVELY SMALL PORTION OF THAT
OF THE PLANNED REVIEWS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED -- THE SECOND IS THAT
WE HAVE SOME WORK LOAD --
CONCERNS AND WE THINK IT'S AN
PLACES THAT WORK WITH JUST
OCCASIONS ARE INSUFFICIENT OF
FOR EXAMPLE WITH REGULATION UNIT --
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT DOES DO
SOME WORK ASSOCIATED WITH --
REVIEWING REGULATIONS THAT PORTS
AND BUREAUS HAVE IT DOESN'T
APPEAR THAT THERE AT WORK LOAD --
BASICALLY TOOK INTO ACCOUNT THAT
WORK WITH THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING BASED ON REGULATION REVIEW
UPSET WHEN EXAMPLE WE HAVE --
SOME OTHER EXAMPLES AS WELL.
EXPLAIN THAT JUST A LITTLE BIT
MORE IS MORE.
PRO READ A THE YEAH HI YEAH SO.
ESSENTIALLY DCA PROVIDES A
VARIETY OF ADMINISTRATIVE SORT
OF CENTRALIZED SERVICES TO THE
BOARDS IN BUREAUS WITHIN THAT
DEPARTMENT THERE ABOUT THIRTY
SEVEN BOARDS AND BUREAUS.
AND THOSE INCLUDE THINGS LIKE I
COUNTING SERVICES HR SERVICES --
LEGAL SERVICES TODAY HAVE
ATTORNEYS -- BUT THEY ALSO DO
THINGS LIKE THERE'S AN
INVESTIGATION UNIT THAT DOES NOT
HAVE SWORN OFFICERS AND THOSE
OFFICERS CAN DO USE
INVESTIGATIONS IN TERMS OF
ENFORCEMENT CASES.
SO SOME OF THEIR FUNCTIONS ARE
FUNDED BASED ON USAGE SO FOR
EXAMPLE I DO WHY THE
INVESTIGATIONS -- THOSE THOSE
FOLKS WHO GO OUT AND DO THOSE --
DESTINATION FOR SWORN OFFICERS
THEY CHARGE THE INDIVIDUAL
BOARDS IN BUREAUS BASED ON THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THEY SPEND
ON THOSE INVESTIGATIONS.
OTHER SERVICES ARE OF FUNDED
DIFFERENTLY FOR EXAMPLE THERE
LEGAL SERVICES I THOSE ARE FINE
DID BASED ON PRO RATA SO
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
DOES IS IT LOOKS AT THE LEGAL
SERVICES THE COST OF THOSE LEGAL
SERVICES.
AND THEN ALLOCATED OUT ON TO THE
BOARD ANDYOUR IS BASED ON HOW
MANY POSITIONS EACH BOARDING
BUREAU HAS NOT BASED ON HOW MUCH
THE USE LEGAL SERVICES. TO
CURRENTLY THEY'RE NOT TRACKING
FOR EXAMPLE THE NUMBER OF HOURS
THAT THEIR ATTORNEYS ARE
SPENDING ON EACH BOARD IN
BUREAUS WORKLOAD.
I SAW IN THE PAST THERE WAS SOME
CONCERN.
THAT THERE MIGHT BE SOME CROSS
SUBSIDIZATION FOR EXAMPLE THAT
SOME OF THE BOARDS -- OR BUREAUS
THAT ARE LARGER -- MIGHT PURPORT
THEY'RE PAYING PROPORTIONALLY
MORE FOR THOSE SERVICES NAY MY
UP USING PROPORTIONALLY MORE
THAT WAS A CONCERN THAT'S COME
UP IN THE PAST.
ON THAT WAS.
THIS I REQUEST THAT THE
DEPARTMENT TO THIS EVALUATION
AND LOOK FOR EFFICIENCIES -- AND
SO THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE'RE
HOPING TO UNDERSTAND THROUGH
THESE REVIEWS AND THEY STARTED
THEM AND THEY DID THE FIRST ONE
WHICH ACTUALLY WAS ON THE
REGULATIONS.
UNIT WHICH IS ONE PIECE OF THEIR
ATTORNEY WORKLOAD -- BUT THEY
HAVE SEVERAL MORE THAT ARE
PLANNED AND WE EXPECT TO GET IN
THE COMING.
YEARS OR SOUR I THINK THERE ARE
SOME THAT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
DEFINITIVE DATE TIME.
THE HELP YES THANK YOU ANYTHING
THAT YOU WANNA.
RESPOND -- ADD TO THAT.
MADAM CHAIR DENNIS KHUSRO DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT -- SO IT'S SIMPLY
WANTED SPEAKER AS IT RELATES TO
TWO ISSUES.
ONE OF THE CMP'S.
IT WAS NEVER THE DEPARTMENT
INTENTION TO GET IN FRONT OF THE
LEGISLATURE -- WE ALWAYS IF YOU
LOOK AT THE BUDGET LANGUAGE
THERE WAS NOTHING IN THE BUDGET
LANGUAGE THAT -- PROHIBITED THE
DEPARTMENT FROM -- REQUESTING
ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION -- OR
ARE FUNDING THE SO THE
REGULATION PIECE WAS --
SOMETHING THAT IS HAS BEEN THE
BIGGEST CRITICISM OF DCA WHEN WE
GET.
FEEDBACK FROM OUR BOARDS IN
BUREAUS IN TERMS OF THE
TIMELINESS -- I HAVE MY DEPUTY
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE LEGAL
AFFAIRS DIVISION THAT COULD
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE TO THIS.
BUT THIS IS A DIRECT RESPONSE TO
TRY TO MEET THE DEMANDS OF THE
BOARDS -- THEY THEY HAVE
ADDITIONAL NEEDS AND THIS
REQUEST IS -- MEANT TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS IN ADDITION TO AS MY
COLLEAGUE JANICE MENTIONED. TO
ME THAT THEY NEED TO AT THE
NEEDS OF AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT THAT WAS PASSED LAST YEAR --
SO SIMPLY TRYING TO BE
RESPONSIVE AS THE DEPARTMENT IS
A FOCUS ON CONSUMER AFFAIRS IT
IS CHALLENGING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT -- TO SIMPLY WAIT
WHEN THERE MIGHT BE ESSENTIAL
NEEDS TO ENSURE OUR CONSUMER
MANDATE -- AND BY DOING SO AND
WAITING TWO YEARS UNTIL THE OLD
OLD -- TO THE CM PROCESS IS
COMPLETED.
WE THINK THAT MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT CHALLENGING -- SO SIMPLY
WANTED TO MAKE THAT COMMENT.
THANK YOU.
DANIEL I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF ADMINISTRATION AT THE CA I
ALSO WANTED TO ASK THOUGH --
DENNIS'S REMARKS AND ALSO POINT
OUT THAT OUR PERRETTA SERVICES
ARE LIMITED TERM SO GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS.
THAT OUR BOARDS EMBARRASSED HAVE
RAISED AND WE WOULD THEN HAVE TO
POSITION TO EXPIRE WE CAN
REVISIT THEM WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
IN A TWO YEAR OR THREE YEAR
FASHION AS PROPOSED BY THE
BUDGET [inaudible]
YES.
IT'S NOT A PART OF FINANCE --
THE RICHEST IN RESPONSE TO THE
IS CONCERNS WE JUST ONE THING
THAT WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
I REQUEST AS PROPOSED.
AS THE DEPARTMENT MENTIONED
ALREADY WE JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE PROVIDER
RESOURCES -- FOR THE DEDICATED
REGULATIONS UNIT AND THE COUNTY
OF THE SCHOOL SERVICES ARE
THAT'S ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS.
THIS IS GOING TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
SHOULD DRESS MORE -- IMMEDIATE
ISSUES AND WORKLOAD ISSUE A
INCREASES WHILE STILL ALLOWING
FOR SUBSEQUENT -- EVALUATION OF
THE ONGOING RESOURCE NEEDS BASED
ON THESE ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
MANAGEMENT REVIEWS THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE -- WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT FISCALE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROCESS SEES AND TO YOUR LIMITED
TERM RESOURCES ARE NECESSARY --
TO HELP THEM ADDRESS THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD THAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING -- ALSO SUPPORTIVE
OF THE REGULATIONS UNIT REQUEST --
BECAUSE THERE'S A CAPACITY ISSUE
THE EXISTING STAFF SIMPLY RIGHT
NOW SIMPLY CAN'T ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT VOLUME OF
REGULATIONS -- INCLUDING THE
INCREASE WORKING FROM AB --
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT THIS
DEDICATED UNIT ONE PROVE -- OF
THE QUALITY.
OF AND REDUCE THE EXISTING
TALENTS OF THE REGULATIONS AND
US DEPARTMENT MENTION THIS HAS
BEEN A CONCERN OF THE FOURTH.
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A CONCERN OF
THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL.
AND THIS IS ALSO THE PROVIDER
WORKING GROUP'S HIGHEST PRIORITY
FOR THEIR THEIR ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT REVIEWS.
AND WE WOULDN'T KNOW THAT --
ESTABLISHING THE DEDICATED UNIT
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS -- IN THE MARCH
FIRST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
REPORT FROM THE FIRST COMPLETED --
OF ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
MANAGEMENT REVIEW [inaudible]
NO -- PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
HEARING NONE [inaudible]
OKAY -- THERE WERE HOLDEN OKAY
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD
OFFICE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE [inaudible]
ISSUE
.
TWENTY THE END OF THE ISSUE
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM DOCTOR
MORRIS IM THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
OF THE CALIFORNIA BORDER REYES
TO NURSING INTO MY LEFT WE HAVE.
STACEY BERMAN THIS IS AN
EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
AND CRISTINA SPRING DEPUTY CHIEF
LICENSING.
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING THE
BOARD OPPORTUNITY TO DRESS.
THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL --
TODAY IN THE FORM.
AND AS YOU'RE PROBABLY YOU'RE
PROBABLY AWARE THE BORDER RAGE
TO NURSING REGULATES.
THE PRACTICE ARE REGISTERED
NURSES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BOARD IMPLEMENTS AND
ENFORCES A NURSING PRACTICE ACT
IS LAWS AND REGULATIONS RELATED
TO NURSING EDUCATION.
LICENSURE PRACTICE AND
DISCIPLINE.
THE BAR REGULATES OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND LICENSEES IN
CALIFORNIA HIS RESPONSE FOR SAID
IN THE EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS FOR
REGISTERED NURSES.
NURSE MIDWIVES IN OTHER ADVANCED
PRACTICE NURSES.
WE ALSO OVERSEE A HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE NURSING PROGRAMS AND
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED EDUCATE.
PROVIDERS CONTINUING EDUCATION
PROVIDERS.
DOING THE BOARDS LAST BUDGET
HEARING THERE ARE SEVERAL ISSUES
REYES REGARDING DIVORCED
INTERNAL BUSINESS OPERATIONS.
PROCESSES.
LAUGHING MATTERS AND THE ABILITY
TO RESPOND TO CONSUMERS IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
AS OF TODAY I'M PROUD TO SAY.
ME THOSE MATTERS HAVE BEEN
RESOLVED AND ARE UPDATED.
THE BOARD STAFF HAS WORKED
EXTENSIVELY BY RESPONDING TO THE
FOLLOWING PROGRAMMATIC AND
OPERATIONAL CHANGES.
WE'LL MODERNIZE OUR PROCESS IS
BASED ON SEVERAL INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL AUDITS.
THE BOARD HAS WORKED WITH PCA'S
FISCAL DEPARTMENT AND A SOLID
OCCUPATIONAL CHANGE MANAGEMENT
TEAM TO REVIEW THE BOARD'S
PROBLEMATIC NEEDS AND AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT.
THE BOARD IS ALSO INCREASE ITS
FEES OF HIS CONSTITUENTS.
IN ORDER TO MEET THE OPERATIONAL
DEMANDS.
OF THE BOARD TO BETTER SERVE THE
PUBLIC.
AND FOR THE THIRD STRAIGHT YEAR
SENATOR ON BURKE.
WE HAVE CREATED THIS SYNERGY
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS -- BY.
EMAIL IN THEM A A A CUSTOMER
SERVICE QUESTIONNAIRE.
AND THIS INCLUDES NOT ONLY OUR
LICENSEES BUT ALSO HOSPITALS AND
OTHER COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
AND WE WE USED THE CONSTRUCTIVE
FEEDBACK.
I'M FROM THE OF THE
QUESTIONNAIRES TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE CHANGES AS NEEDED --
INTERFACING AND LEVERAGES.
POINT [inaudible]
CONSTANTLY.
THAT'S HOW WE MEASURE THE
OUTCOME.
YEAH.
YES AND SO HOWEVER.
HOWEVER THOSE ARE ON THEIR ITEMS
ADDRESS AND I'M IN FRONT OF YOU
AND THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL.
THAT THAT THE THE STILL ARE
REMAINS MATTERS OF CONCERN.
SO BUT SO THE COLLECTIVE INPUT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND ALEJO.
THE BOARD FEELS THAT THE SIXTY
SEVEN POSITION THE REQUESTED NOT
ONLY ALLOW US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVE OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE.
BUT ALSO BETTER PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND RESPOND TO MATTERS OF
CONCERNED.
MUCH SOONER THAN LATER.
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
MEMBERS THE ENTIRE BE ARE IN
STAFF THAT ARE LOOKING --
ADDRESS TODAY.
AND THE STAFF IS THAT BEFORE YOU
TODAY WE ASKED RESPECTFULLY FOR
YOUR SUPPORT -- IN NOW BUDGET
CHANGE COMPOSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO CONCERN FOR THE PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
FINAL -- LIKE TO ASK.
THIS IS A VERY DRAMATIC
[inaudible]
INCREASE.
THE SIXTY SEVEN POSITION.
CAN YOU DEFINE DRAMATIC
[inaudible] SIXTY SEVEN IT IS
SOME AND I'M JUST I'M I'M
CURIOUS AS TO WHY THIS.
IT LOOKS SEVEN FOR US YES RIGHT
COULD NOT HAVE HAD IT AND THEN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PAST.
HISTORY IS IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU
ASK.
FOR IN THE PAST BUT SIXTY SEVEN
IS A I MEAN.
WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT FIFTY
YEAH AND THE YOU KNOW INNOVATION
TECHNOLOGY NAY ASKING.
FOR SIXTY SEVEN HI HOW DO YOU
EXPLAIN THIS.
BIG JUMP IF I MAY GIVE YOU ME MY
HUMBLE OPINION THE NOW WILL OF
POINT TO STAFF SO THEY CAN GIVE
YOU MORE.
DETAIL.
RESPECTFULLY THE BOARD AGAIN WE
SEE WE OVERSEE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND LICENSEES.
PERHAPS THE LARGEST HILL IN ART
BOARDS IN THE UNITED STATES AND
THAT THE BOARD HAS NOT.
YET INCREASES FEES IN OVER TEN
YEARS.
ALSO WITHIN TEN YEARS WE'VE SEEN
OUR NUMBER OF LICENSEE
POPULATION ALMOST DOUBLE.
THEN SO.
WHAT THAT LITTLE DRAMATIC
CHANGES IS ALSO CREATED MORE
DEMAND -- ON THE BOARD TO TO TO
RESPOND TO THE CONSUMER NEEDS.
ON SOME ADDITIONAL BACKGROUND WE
HAVE -- SUBMITTED PROPOSALS AND
THE PAST THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
COMPLETELY SUCCESSFUL -- AND WE
WERE ALSO MADE AWARE THAT YOU
KNOW WE DIDN'T HAVE NECESSARILY
BE FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT FIVE AND A NUMBER OF
POSITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
REQUESTED.
AND SO WE DID HAVE A FIAT IT'S
APPROXIMATELY FOUR YEARS AGO.
ON THE BOARD VOTED -- TO
INCREASE THE MAJORITY OF THE
FEES THAT THE BOARD OF CHARGES
AND THEY WERE PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE SO WE HAVE LOOKED AT
ALL OF OUR VARIOUS PROCESSES.
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE -- WHERE
WE NEEDED TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
IN ORDER TO IMPROVE OUR CUSTOMER
SERVICE AS WELL AS OUR
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS?
DID YOU ON A BREAKDOWN OF THE
THE POSITIONS AS WELL SO SIXTY
SEVEN DOES SOUND LIKE A LARGE
NUMBER NO I I HAVE THEM WELL
WELL IT'S NOT ALL BRAND NEW
POSITIONS.
SO THEY'RE MAKING SIXTEEN
POSITIONS THAT WERE LIMITED TERM
BCP POSITIONS.
I'M A COUPLE OF BUDGET CYCLES
AGO PERMANENT SO IT'S PERMANENT
FUNDING FOR THOSE POSITIONS THAT
ALREADY EXIST WITH THE BOARD.
THERE ARE TWENTY EIGHT LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THE BCP THAT WE WILL EVALUATE
OUR PROCESSES DETERMINE IF -- WE
HAVE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES IF WE
NEED TO MAKE ANY OF THOSE
PERMANENT THEN WE WILL COME BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK TO
MAKE SOME OF THOSE ARE ALL OF
THOSE IF NEEDED.
PERMANENT WHICH OF REMAINS
TWENTY THREE POSITIONS ARE
ACTUALLY ALL THAT THE BOARD IS
GETTING PERMANENT FULL TIME
POSITIONS.
FOR ARE SEEKING.
I'M SURE YES -- I JUST WANTED TO
ADD THAT IN THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS THE BOARD HAS REQUESTED --
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES BUT WE ONLY
APPROVE THEM ON A LIMITED TERM
BASIS BECAUSE OF THAT THE IT.
THE FUNDING ISSUE WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT.
ON GOING THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE THAT.
IS A PART OF MY QUESTION IS WHEN
YOU SAID THE A PROPOSED HAVE NOT
BEEN SUCCESSFUL YOU MEAN YOU
HAVEN'T GOT THE POSITIONS YOU
ASKED FOR OR YOU DID GET HIM AND
THAT DIDN'T WORK OUT THE WAY
YOU'D HOPED.
WE DID NOT GET ALL OF THE
POSITIONS THAT WE ASKED.
FOR SO IS THERE OF SOME SORT OF
CONTINUING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT WE CAN NO
IF WE APPROVE THE SIXTY SEVEN
POSITIONS THAT THE BACKLOG IS
COMING DOWN.
THE RATES COMING DOWN THAT KIND
OF STUFF.
SO IT.
AS THE B. C. B. STANDS RIGHT NOW
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE THAT BU
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT NEED IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
OKAY BUT WILL LOOK TO THE LA ALL --
SO THAT WE CAN.
SERVE ED ACCOUNTABILITY.
OKAY -- JUST ONE MORE QUESTION
THIS [inaudible]
YEAH.
IS THE UP THE WORKLOAD DURING
WORK LOAD I HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH MORE COMPLAINTS.
OR IS THAT.
SORT OF NORMAL IT'S A NORMAL
LEVEL.
YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT AN
DID YOU SEE AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF LICENSES.
SEC SO WE LICENSE LICENSEES
LICENSEES.
SURE SO SO OUR COMPLAINT WORK
THAT HAS GONE UP -- IT'S NOT AS
DRAMATIC ANYMORE THE THE
INCREASE IN THE COMPLAINT
WORKLOAD -- HOWEVER WE'RE
PROJECTED TO RECEIVE OVER TEN
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS THIS YEAR WE
HAD APPROXIMATELY NINETY SEVEN
HUNDRED COMPLAINTS LAST YEAR BUT
AS THE NUMBER OF LICENSEES
INCREASES.
IT'S SORT OF EXPECTED THAT THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS WILL ALSO
GO UP AS WELL [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY A PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
OKAY HEARING NONE.
JUST ONE THING I WANTED TO ADD
ON THE REPORTING -- SO
HISTORICALLY THE DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS HAS DONE
REPORTING ON THEIR LICENSE TIME
LINES AS WELL AS THEIR
ENFORCEMENT TIME LINES AND
THERE'S BEEN.
AND THAT'S BEEN INCLUDED AS PART
OF THE BUDGET I UNDERSTAND THERE
BEEN SOME CHALLENGES WITH THEIR
SORT OF MOVED TO BREEZE AND SOME
OF THE ENTITIES HAVEN'T HAVEN'T.
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE ALL OF THAT
BUT I BUT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS HISTORICALLY
PROVIDED ON AN ANNUAL BASIS AND
I THINK IS ABSOLUTELY REASONABLE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO REQUEST
ON IN THE FUTURE AS WELL.
ADDITIONALLY ADDITION YOU KNOW
IF THERE'S INTEREST IN
ADDITIONAL TYPES OF REPORTING
CERTAINLY THAT -- THAT.
THE BOARD COULD THAT COULD
CERTAINLY WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND AND OUR OFFICE
TO THINK BOUT OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS THAT COULD BE HELPFUL FOR
EXAMPLE HISTORICALLY -- LAST FEW
YEARS THE BOARD HAS HAD SOME
ISSUES WITH YOU KNOW CALLS BEING
DROPPED THOSE KINDS OF THINGS IF
THERE ARE METRICS LIKE THAT DAY
OUR PARTICULAR INTEREST TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
I'M CERTAINLY WOULD BE
REASONABLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO TO ASK THE BOARD TO A REPORT
ON THOSE OUTCOMES TO ENSURE THAT
I'M WHATEVER KINDS OF OUTCOME
MEASURES LEGISLATURE'S MOST
INTERESTED IN.
ARE REALLY BEING ACHIEVED
THROUGH THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
OKAY.
GREAT -- ALL RIGHT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD OPEN --
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR WORK
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE SO
WE'LL WE'LL.
WE'LL ASK YOU TO TELL US WHAT
METRIC YOU THINK IS REASONABLE
FOR US TO ASSESS SO THAT.
NO WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW BI
MONTHLY REPORTING WHATEVER IT IS
WE WOULD BE INTERESTED IN SEEING
WHAT PROGRESS IS BEING MADE.
ASSUMING THAT THE SIXTY SEVEN
POSITIONS.
BOB PART OF YOUR OKAY YES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NOW WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL THIS IS OUR LAST.
THE LAST ITEM ON THE AGENDA
.
GOOD AFTERNOON I I ALMOST SAY
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
WELCOME.
Q..
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR.
NUMBER -- I'M AND BOUND CRAWFORD
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
THANKS FOR PUTTING OUR BUDGET ON
THE COMMITTEE AGENDA.
FOR SENATE SUB.
FOR I'M HERE TODAY WITH THE MY
STAFF DIRECTOR.
OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS CHRISTIAN
MARGOLIS.
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO GOVERNOR NEW
SAM FOR HIS JANUARY PROPOSAL AS
AS THE TEN MILLION ON GOING
INCREASED TO OUR BUDGET FOR THE
FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY LAST WEEK OUR
BUDGET WAS HEARD IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND BUDGET SO FOR COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE OTED TO LEAVE OUR
ITEM OPEN.
THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL GRANT PORTFOLIO IS
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO ARTS
AND CULTURE THAT'S RELEVANT AND
RESPONSIVE TO THEM.
HOWEVER WE HAVE SOME PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
MAKING SURE SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES
HAVE ACCESS TO ARTS AND CULTURE.
IN OUR FUNDING YEARS SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WE MADE THE COMMITMENT
TO ALLOCATE APPROXIMATELY SIX
POINT SIX MILLION. TO FIND
SPECIFIC UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
LOW INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
AM SOME OF THESE ARE A LOCAL
IMPACT WHICH AT THAT PROGRAM
SUPPORTS COMMUNITY DRIVEN ARTS
PROJECTS FOR SMALL TO MID SIZED
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS.
CULTURAL PATHWAYS -- THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES TWO YEARS OF
OPERATING SUPPORT AND A HOST OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES TO SMALL -- NEW AN
EMERGENCY ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
ROOTED IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
RECENT IMMIGRANT REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES AND TRIBAL OR
INDIGENOUS AND GROUPS.
WE HAVE A VETERANS IN THE ARTS --
THE GRANT [inaudible]
ARENA WHERE.
THIS PROGRAM IS ROOTED IN OUR
COUNCIL'S DESIRE TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS AND IMPROVE THE LIVES.
OF CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS THROUGH
THE ARTS WE ALSO FIND A VETERANS
IN THE ARTS I MEAN I'VE READ A
RE ENTRY THROUGH THE ARTS.
PROGRAM.
WHICH IS SUPPORT HIGH QUALITY
ARTS PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE WHO'VE
BEEN CONVICTED OF A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE.
AND HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME IN
CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
ALSO JUMPSTART'S PROGRAM.
HEY ADAM THIS IS JUMPSTART'S AS
A HIGH QUALITY ARTS EDUCATION AN
ARTIST IN RESIDENCE PROGRAM. FOR
YOUTH ENGAGED IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM I INCLUDE THIS
CITY -- TO WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT INCARCERATION
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
SO IT SOUNDS.
IT BELONGS IN THIS GROUP AS DOES
ARTS EDUCATION.
EXPOSURE WHICH PRIMARILY SERVES
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS.
WHERE MOST STUDENT ATTENDEES --
ARE UNDERSERVED IN TERMS OF
THEIR ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
ARTS EDUCATION ART SOME
EXPERIENCES AND ARTS EDUCATION.
I AM THIS PARTICULAR GRANT.
PROGRAM THAT SUPPORTS AT TENDONS
TWO PERFORMANCES AND EXHIBITS
FOR STUDENTS WHO HAVE LIMITED
ASK ACCESS TO THOSE EXPERIENCES.
RIGHT -- KRISTIN HERE SO THAT WE
CAN.
BOTH SHE'S PART OF MY COLLECTED
BRAIN AS IT WERE AND WE CAN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE [inaudible]
OKAY.
GET A RAISE ANY CONCERNS
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
CALL.
JUST CLICK UP.
I BELIEVE SUPPORT THIS WANT ONE
OF OUR CHALLENGES IT.
CONSTITUENTS SAY YOU KNOW IF WE
JUST DIDN'T HAVE THE ARTS BUDGET
THAT OUR STATE BUDGET CRISIS
WOULD BE RESOLVED OR ANY STATE
DEFICIT WOULD BE RESOLVED WE ALL
KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT ACCURATE.
IN TERMS.
THE OR SHIP FUNDING IT'S VERY
VERY SMALL -- WOULD BE USEFUL IS
IF AND I SAY THIS EARLIER TODAY
IF THERE WAS SOME SORT OF METRIC.
IT'S JUST MY OBSERVATION THAT
ARTS FOR EXAMPLE IN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES AT ACTUALLY HAS.
A BENEFIT NOT JUST TO THE PERSON
WHO IS PARTICIPATING BUT HAS A
BENEFIT TERMS OF POSITIVISM ALL
KINDS OF THINGS AND AND THERE'S
THERE'S OTHER.
BENEFITS BESIDES TO THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS PARTICIPATING
SO TO THE EXTENT.
TODAY TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT THINK THAT'S
HELPFUL.
IF THERE IS A WAY THAT'S THAT'S
HELPFUL FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME TO
EXPLAIN TO OUR CONSTITUENTS Y.
TAXPAYERS ARE PROVIDING. TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THOSE ARE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT TO US AS WELL.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT WE
ACTUALLY ARE PLANNING TO USE A
GOOD PORTION OF THE FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED FOR
EVALUATION -- AND THOSE WOULD
CERTAINLY BE SHARED WITH EVERY
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION -- IN
ADDITION WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
A STRATEGIC STRATEGIC PLANNING
FRAMEWORK PROCESS -- AND THAT IS
REALLY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
WELL INFORMED OF WHAT THEY NEED
IS IN IN EVERYONE'S DISTRICT AND
SO WE PLAN ON REACHING OUT TO
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AS WELL AS EVERY AND EVERYONE
ELSE IN THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
I'M TO GET INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES -- I THINK THAT AND
PROVIDED A REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE
OF THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE AND HOW ARE OUTRAGE IS
REALLY TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
THOSE -- AFFORDABLE IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN
WE FOLLOW THE CENSUS RICHARDS --
QUESTIONS -- WE DID IN THE IN
THE ASSEMBLY HEARING AS WELL AND
AND WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON
THOSE SAME POPULATIONS AND
TRYING TO REACH EVERYONE -- AND
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT VALUE IS
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT AND WE ARE
DEFINITELY GOING TO WORK ON THAT
AND SHARE THAT WITH INFORMATION
WITH YOU THAT'S GREAT SO I'M FOR
EXAMPLE CHILDREN WHO EXPERIENCED
TRAUMA.
ARE VERY HEALTHY LIKE YOURSELF.
RIGHT IF THE HEALING PROCESS
RIGHT EXACTLY SO YOU GONNA TELL
US.
WHAT NUMBERS WE CAN USE?
TO BE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
THANK YOU SIR WE HAVE A LOT OF
GOOD STORIES BUT THE NUMBERS ARE.
FOUNDATION ABOUT [inaudible]
I'M.
I COULD I COULD SEE HERE.
BY THE WAY THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK I THINK ARTS ARE
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF
I COMMUNITIES AND AND EDUCATION
OVERALL -- THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR TRYING TO
SPREAD IT OUT MORRELL.
I MEAN TO TO GIVE FIFTY SIX
GRAMS. FOR A TOTAL OF FORTY FOUR
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
THEY MIGHT GET NINETY NINE CENTS
EACH RIGHT I MEAN.
I'M JUST GETTING.
THE POINT IS A HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE GRANTS FOR ONE POINT NINE
MILLION -- AND IT GOES ON AND ON
AND ON SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
WHAT I HAVE SEEN IN IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN OTHER AREAS IS.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S AN ENORMOUS
NEED -- HOW DO WE FEEL THAT NEED
WHAT'S THE STRATEGY TO FEEL THE
NEED TO DO THAT YOU KNOW TAKE
OUT AND?
BE CREATIVE BOB THE KINDS OF
ARTS THAT ARE NEEDED AD THAT
CAN BE DONE IN OUR COMMUNITY SO.
IT'S IT YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO
LEARN MORE WE DON'T HAVE TO DO
IT ALL TODAY BUT WHAT'S A REAL
STRATEGY TO USE OUR RESOURCES.
IN THE BEST WAY -- WE HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE IN AN RIGHT OUTSIDE OF
MY DISTRICT BUT SERVING THE
NEEDS OF MY DISTRICT.
OF JUST A HANDFUL OF THEATERS.
LIVE THEATERS AND THEY'RE REALLY
SMALL BUT HOW DO WE ALLOW THEM
TO WORK ONE THEATER IN
PARTICULAR REPRESENTS -- DOES --
WORK IN THREE ETHNIC --
COMMUNITIES SO HOW DO WE USE A
REGION MODEL A REGIONAL MODEL
RIGHT -- OR SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF THE
RESOURCES.
OF THAT'S ONE QUESTION THE OTHER
IS.
LOOKING UP TO BUILD.
AND NOT ONLY GIVE.
YOU KNOW TWENTY THOUSAND HERE
ARE FIVE THOUSAND THERE BUT HOW
DO YOU BUILD AN INFRASTRUCTURE I
MEAN OUR MAINSTREAM.
QUOTE UNQUOTE YOU KNOW ARTS.
THE BILL THE THE DOROTHY
CHANDLER PAVILION THEY BUILD.
THESE -- PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT ACTUALLY.
IN OVER THE MORTAR I MEAN RIGHT.
THAT'S LEFT THERE SO YOU COULD
SEE A A MUSEUM YOU.
SEE THESE ARE PERMANENT THEY'RE
NOT GOING AWAY AFTER THE FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT.
SO.
I'M INTERESTED IN HOW WE REALLY
DO THAT YEAR AFTER YEAR AND NOT
ONLY SPREAD -- THE MONEY TO YOU
KNOW HUNDREDS OF GROUPS BUT
REALLY BILL SOMETHING PERMANENT
SO THOSE ARE JUST.
TWO YOU CAN COMMENT TODAY BUT
THAT'S WHAT I'M.
I'M I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN I
THINK YOU SHOULD GET MORE THAN
TEN MILLION DOLLARS I REALLY DO
I I JUST DON'T SEE HOW WE DO.
ALL OF THIS GREAT WORK WITH TEN
MILLION DOLLARS BUT I THINK IT
WOULD COME WITH.
A REAL PLAN RIGHT RIGHT BILL
SOMETHING PERMANENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND NOT BE SUBJECT
TO EVERY YEAR DO I GET I
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT'S JUST NOT
GOING TO WORK ARE YOU WRITE IT
SEE IT AND IT SEE IT WOULD SEEM
AS IF IT WOULD MAKE THE WORK ON
SUSTAINABLE.
AND ONE BEING ABLE TO EVALUATE
IN FACT ONE OF MY OUR PRIORITIES
IS TO EVALUATE.
THE IMPACT THAT WE HAVE ARE
HAVING CURRENTLY IN HAVE HAD ON
THE FIELD AND TO EVALUATE HOW WE
ACTUALLY DO DISTURB -- BUTTE
MONEY IN.
CURRENT.
CONTEMPORARY LANDSCAPE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT NETWORKING
OR AND YOU KNOW HOW HOW DO WE?
HOW DO WE BECOME AS IMPACTFUL AS
POSSIBLE ALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE HAVE A PRETTY?
ROBUST SYSTEM A NETWORK OF
COUNTY ARTS COUNCILS.
WE HAVE NAM ARTS COUNCILS THAT
ARE THERE APPOINTED BY THE
COUNTY BOARD ISSUE.
WE FIND THEM.
AND SO THERE ARE WELL VERSED IN
WHAT THEY'RE REGION'S NEED.
AND THAT'S AND AND THAT'S A
NETWORK THAT WE ARE INCREASINGLY
MAKING MORE ROBUST AND KEEP
BETTER CONNECTED AND I'VE I
WOULD LIKE.
TO REINFORCE YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO.
AND MAKE THEM MORE EVEN MORE
EFFICIENT IN THEIR AREAS AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE GET TO THE
BRICK AND MORTAR PART USUALLY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S ALL
I'LL.
LOT MORE RESOURCE BUT IF A
COUNTY AND SEE WHAT RESOURCES
ARE THERE AND WHERE THE NEED IS
MAYBE THERE ARE BRICK AND MORTAR
PLACES WHERE THEY CAN YOU KNOW
FIGURE OUT THE RIGHT AT SOME.
AND ON YOUR RIGHT THIS IS A
LARGER CONVERSATION THAT I'D
LOVE TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE WITH YOU.
I ALSO JUST LIKE TO MAKE ON ONE
POINT IS THAT -- WE ALSO ARE
CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN.
DESIGNATING CULTURAL DISTRICTS
AND THIS IS A LEGISLATIVELY
MANDATED PROGRAM -- AND WHILE
THERE ISN'T A LOT OF MONEY
THAT'S ATTACHED TO IT AT THIS
POINT BECAUSE IT'S IN ITS
FORMATIVE STAGE.
IT'S ABOUT BRINGING PARTNERS
TOGETHER SO SOME OF THOSE
PARTNERS DO CERTAINLY INVOLVED
BROKEN MARTYR.
AND AND OTHER CORPORATE
PARTNERSHIPS BUT HISTORICAL
PARTNERSHIPS -- OUR PARTNERSHIP
BRINGING IN CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION AND
OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS TO AND SO I THINK THOSE
THAT'S ONE WAY THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AS A
STATE WIDE ENTITY CAN REALLY
HELP THE SMALLER ORGANIZATIONS.
CURRENTLY WE FIGURE WE'LL FIND
ABOUT 57% OF THE REQUESTS THAT
COME IN FOR US AND IF YOU LOOK
AT STATEWIDE IN TERMS OF
NONPROFIT ARTS ORGANIZATION
THERE'S ABOUT.
ELEVEN THOUSAND WHICH MEANS WERE
FINDING ABOUT 7% -- SO YES IT
SEEMS LIKE A SMALL AMOUNT BUT
EVERY SINGLE INCREMENTAL
INCREASE TO OUR BUDGET SINCE WE
HAD OUR DEVASTATING CUTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE HAS MADE A
HUGE.
HUGE DIFFERENCE AND WE BELIEVE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND SO WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS.
OPPOSE TEN MILLION DOLLARS IT
JUST YOU EXAMPLE NOW AND WITH
THIS IS THE LA THEATRE COMPANY
ON IN DOWNTOWN LA.
I MEAN WHEN IT WAS RAINING HAD
BUCKETS ALL OVER THE YEAH ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
AND HOW HOW DO YOU THREE WELCOME
PEOPLE.
DID YOU KNOW LOOK AT THE YOU
KNOW -- ATTEND A PLAY.
WHATEVER THE EVENTS IN THE
PROGRAMS AND THEIR DODGING YOU
KNOW THE THE BUCKETS THERE FROM
ALL THE LEAKS IN THE ROOF.
I MEAN YOU CAN'T FOCUS ON THE
CONTENT THEN THE PRODUCION OF
THESE UP PROGRAMS IT SHOWS WHEN.
WHEN YOU GOT TO WORRY ABOUT THAT
OR PAYING THE RENT I MEAN THAT
THIS REALLY?
IT'S REALLY RIDICULOUS AND IT'S
SHAMEFUL WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT
HAPPENS.
ALWAYS IN LOW INCOME AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SO ANYWAY
IT'S A LONGER CONVERSATION BUT
I'M VERY INTERESTED AND I THINK
YOU SHOULD HAVE MORE MONEY.
LISTENING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU BYE [inaudible]
FALLS BROKE.
I THINK WE'RE PROOF.
RAZA YES.
CENTER NIELSEN SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH.
OKAY -- I'M SO SORRY.
I AM SO SORRY.
YES I AM I APOLOGIZE THAT'S OKAY
I'M MY NAME'S JULIE BAKER AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR THEARTS
STATEWIDE ARTS ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FIRST FULL THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR
AMBERG.
NOT GONNA TALK YOU OUT OF IT I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ACTUALLY I JUST
WANNA SAY AS A CITIZEN WHO'S
BEEN HERE SINCE THE BEGINNING.
SO.
IMPRESSED BY BOTH OF YOU IN
TERMS OF YOUR ACTIVE LISTENING
AND YOUR COMPASSION AND INTEREST
IN ALL OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
BROUGHT TODAY.
BUT I AM HERE TO SPEAK DIRECTLY
ABOUT THE ARTS AND I JUST WANTED
TO BRING OUT SOME STATISTICS AND
METRICS AND THINGS THAT WE CAN
LOOK AT IN TERMS OF WHERE WE ARE.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT CAL AND
YOU'RE WELCOME TO STAND BECAUSE
I KNOW WE'RE READY TO GO.
WE BELIEVE THAT -- CALIFORNIA IS
THE LEADING STATE OF CREATIVITY
AND SHOULD BE THE STATE OF THE
ART -- BUT WHERE WE ARE EVEN
WITH THIS TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WE'RE STILL UNDER ONE DOLLAR PER
PERSON PER CAPITA.
TERMS OF FUNDING THE ARTS SO
COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE NEED FOR
MORE THE MEDIAN IS A DOLLAR TEN
ACROSS THE NATION SO WE'RE NOT
WHERE WE SHOULD BE AT ALL.
BUT WE DO KNOW ALSO INCREDIBLE
NUMBERS COMING OUT OF THE PURE
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS WHICH IS
SHOWING THAT THE STATE'S
CREATIVE ECONOMY FOR CALIFORNIA.
IS SEVEN POINT 1% OF GROSS STATE
PRODUCT.
THIS IS THE HEAD OF AGRICULTURE
AND TRANSPORTATION IS A REALLY
IMPRESSIVE NUMBERS AND TALKING
ABOUT HOW DO YOU SPEAK TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ON WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CREATE PIPE LINE.
TERMS OF ARTS ED AND PROGRAM SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE THIS CREATIVE
ECONOMY CONTINUE TO FUEL
CALIFORNIA THESE ARE THE NUMBERS
THAT WE AS CALIFORNIANS FOR THE
ARTS AND THE DATA AND TELLING
THE STORIES WILL BE CONTINUING
TO PUT OUT THERE SO.
WE ABSOLUTELY SAY THIS FUNDING
SHOULD NOT ONLY BE.
INSTITUTED THIS YEAR BUT SHOULD
OF COURSE INCREASE TO THE
NUMBERS THAT WE SHOULD BE IN
TERMS OF WHERE WE SHOULD BE
ASKED CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO RICHLY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S CHRIS
VERTIGO I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
GAY MEN'S CHORUS.
AND NOW THE BRAND NEW NATIONAL
LGBTQ.
ARTS CENTER.
WHICH WE ARE LAUNCHING LATER
THIS FALL.
SO IT IS -- IT'S VERY EXCITING --
BUT WHAT I WANT TO SPEAK TO
REALLY QUICKLY -- IS.
A GIFT THAT WE RECEIVE ACTUALLY
I WAS ALSO THE CEO OF THE GAY
MEN'S CHORUS OF LOS ANGELES AND
DURING THAT TIME -- WE VENTURED
OUT ON A A NEW PROGRAM --
ENTITLED -- THE ALLIED MUSIC
PROJECT WHICH WENT INTO --
YOU'RE NODDING SO I FEEL LIKE
MUSIC PROJECT WHICH WENT INTO --
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE LA A A LA COUNTY EL
USC.
AND IT WAS REALLY FOCUS RIGHT
LGBT.
YOUTH AND THE ARTS AND PROVIDING
THEM REALLY OF A WINDOW INTO
WHAT'S POSSIBLE AND INTO HOW.
THROUGH THE ARTS YOUR LIFE CAN
ACTUALLY GET BETTER YOU CAN SIT
IN A SPACE OF AUTHENTICITY --
THAT PROGRAM -- RECEIVED A FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AND IT
WAS THAT THAT THEN BECAME A
MODEL FOR THE PROGRAM WE NOW
HAVE IN SAN FRANCISCO WHICH IS
CALLED THE RHYTHM AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO GAY MEN'S CHORUS.
AND FOR OTHER PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT'S HOW IMPORTED
THIS KIND OF FUNDING IS YOU KNOW
THIS YOU ALL KNOW THIS IT IS
WONDERFUL I CAN ONLY ECHO.
WHICH HE SAID IT IS WONDERFUL TO
SIT IN A ROOM WHERE YOU HAVE
LEGISLATORS TO ACTUALLY GET IT --
AND THAT IS SO -- REASSURING AND
YOUNG VIC REINVIGORATING FOR US --
SO I JUST YOU KNOW YOU'RE RIGHT
TEN MILLION ISN'T ENOUGH IF YOU
CAN GET TWENTY I THINK THAT BE
GREAT AND WILL BE APPLYING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
THANK YOU.
I KNOW.
ME.
TOO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY ALL THE
STAFF THREE SHADES.
YEAH RIGHT.
THANK.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW.
I'M